Hello, everybody!
It's me, Tokyo!
And I might sound really weird because I finally plugged in my new mic this morning.
I know I should have done it after my stream yesterday when my sound guy was still alive.
He still is.
Sorry.
Yeah, I sound very different.
I know.
I sound really weird.
Like, I... I know.
Yeah.
So, um... I don't know how to do anything.
I don't know what to do.
I was adjusting my mic and I... I don't... Yeah, I sound... I know!
I sound like I'm in somewhere else.
I don't know.
So, like... Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna... Alright.
We're gonna figure this out together until sound people are alive.
Like, I don't think anybody... I, like, even sent it to my manager and was like...
Like, I sound so weird.
And then my manager, like... I can see that they're online.
But, like, they never replied back.
I don't know.
My entire staff team, like, disappeared.
For some fucking reason.
I, like, I... I messaged, like, three people.
And, like, I got left on read.
I, like... So, like, I see them.
I... Okay.
Sound guy is offline.
I see that they're offline.
Our main sound person is offline.
But, I see my manager online.
I, like, but I was left on read.
I... I was...
I never... They never said anything back on read.
I...
Okay.
So, we'll figure this out to... I'm gonna show my...
GoXLR settings.
And then, we'll figure this out.
I don't know.
I'm so confused.
Okay.
So, alright, this is either a gate thing or a compressor thing.
So, I'm gonna show you guys several things to, like, help me figure this out.
I'll show you guys several things.
Okay, let me do a text.
Figuring out sound.
My new mic together.
Text together.
Let's see, yeah.
Text support.
Text support with dragoons.
Alright, for those who are like, where's my game?
And it's all in Comic Sans, too.
Alright.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, and then, I don't know.
Maybe someone will get it right.
I have everything saved.
I have all my settings saved.
So, like, if we somehow fuck it up, don't worry.
Because we can always revert it.
Alright, so...
And then we'll figure all of this out together.
Alright.
Only substitutes are online.
Okay.
Alright.
Get that...
Get the substitutes.
Oh my god.
We have one of my staff members alive.
Thank god.
Okay.
Alright.
Get the substitutes in.
We're gonna figure this out.
Alright.
So...
So we have this.
We have this.
Which is...
It's a condenser mic.
So the microphone is a condenser microphone.
We have this.
We have...
Oh.
We have this.
Okay.
Wait.
Let me figure out...
We have this.
Alright.
And then we also have...
There's my other...
We're swinging...
One other image.
Okay.
And then we also have...
We also have this.
I don't know where to put this.
Okay.
We have this as well.
Alright.
One of you guys will figure this out for me.
What...
Okay.
Um...
Alright.
So...
We have...
Okay.
Anyone have any idea...
What to do?
Anyone!
Put all your points into attack.
Okay.
We will figure this out.
The mic meter should be maxed out...
And peaking at all times.
I think.
Alright.
Dude, I...
For the sake of everybody here that's watching...
I feel like...
That should not be what we do.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Have you tried turning it to 11?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Okay.
That's out of the way.
Alright.
It's okay, we get all the bad ideas out of the way, so we can get... So all the ideas left would be the good ideas, right?
So, it's okay.
We're just getting rid of all the bad ideas.
Hey, Doki, today's my birthday, or as a friend told me, womb eviction day.
Can I get a jingle from my Kamiyoshi?
Of course you can, Kongu.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Kongu.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Alright.
Okay.
Do we have any idea?
Do we... Cody, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I was just at an anime convention.
There's so much Doki merch.
Oh my god!
Did you spend any money?
Did you buy them?
Please tell me you did buy them, Cody.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You can't just not buy Doki merch, you know?
Alright.
Turn ratio down and gain up.
What's... Which one's the ratio?
Oh, okay.
Wait.
What do we turn to?
Okay, do you know what ratio is?
Before I do any of that, do you know what it is?
Because I don't.
I...
What even is... Okay.
Gain up?
Okay.
I'm gonna turn the game up, guys.
The gain is up.
Do I sound better?
Or do I sound worse?
Lower the ratio.
Threshold to...
Minus L plus 3.
Okay.
Let me turn it down a little bit more.
Sound... Okay.
Compressor.
Lower the ratio to 3 to 1.
And then...
Um...
There's no 3-1.
There's no...
There's...
4-1.
3.2-1.
2.5-1.
2-1.
There's 2-1.
Why is there no 3-1?
Why...
Why is there...
It's because I turn away from the mic.
Maybe if I...
Maybe if I can...
I could just...
Position it in a way where...
Because when I talk, I turn away a little bit from the mic.
Maybe that's why...
Ooh.
Maybe if I do this...
And then...
Rotate it?
Like that?
Does that...
Is that better?
Um...
3-2-1 should be fine.
Is that...
Is that better?
Or is that worse?
I, like, turned a little bit away...
But, like, also, like, pointed at the mic.
It was better before...
This is worse.
Okay.
Alright.
Let me...
Fix that then.
Okay.
I'll do this.
And then...
Rotate this.
Like that.
And then...
Um...
How about now?
Worse or better?
Also, I'll do...
What was it?
3-2-1.
Okay.
And then...
Raise the threshold to...
Minus 45.
You mean...
Lower the threshold?
Do you mean...
Uh...
Lower...
Lower the threshold?
Or...
Because, okay...
If I sound further away...
When I do this...
It's because, like...
Because I'm looking at my chat.
So my mouth is away from the mic.
Because I'm looking away from my chat.
I'm looking at my chat.
Um...
And...
So raise it to a higher negative?
Oh!
Okay.
I have to look at chat?
What do you mean?
Don't do that.
Okay.
Mine...
It doesn't go to 40.
My threshold...
Does not go to 40...
45, by the way.
Does...
Oh, wait.
Which 40?
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, you mean my gate?
Oh!
On the gate!
Okay.
I put the gate...
Uh...
Sorry.
I...
I put the...
I did on the compressor.
I did it to, like, 40.
Um...
I'm not gonna move the mic when I move my head.
That's way too much work.
I bought a better mic...
So that it improves my sound quality.
And also makes my life easier.
I...
If I'm gonna...
If, like, it's gonna be a fucking problem...
I will go back to my old mic...
And just buy the same old mic, guys.
I thought...
By paying more money...
I do less work.
That's the whole point.
What's the point of paying more money...
If you do more work?
Right, right, right.
That's the...
Okay.
Jokes on you.
I bought...
It's the Newman.
It's the Newman 102.
That's the one I bought.
Um...
Okay.
Is it...
Uh...
Is it better?
Or should we adjust it more?
Is this better or not?
I don't know.
I mean, I could've bought the...
I was debating about the...
The Newman 3...
Instead of the 2...
Like, 103 instead of the 102.
No, these...
Um...
Sound people said that I should get 102 over 103...
Because my room needed more treatment...
If I was gonna get 103.
So, like...
So, I bought the 102...
Because I had...
I can have a less treated room.
I still sound...
Worse?
I sound...
I guess?
Okay, guys.
I...
I'm trying to improve my quality of life here.
Hi, Doki.
I'm a certified audio...
Audio engineer.
I recommend turning the mic volume...
All the way down.
Let's see.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Come here.
All right.
What else do I do?
Sorry.
I'm like further...
Now I'm closer to the mic.
Okay.
Is there anything else I can do?
This new thing was expensive.
So, I'm gonna make it work.
Real, Doki.
Real.
Robert.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I was told...
That...
This was gonna be an improvement...
From my old mic.
So, we are going to improve this.
Okay?
I have to sound...
Better...
Than what I did before.
I do not want to sound weird.
All right.
Sound...
Substitute sound people.
I did all the other stuff.
What else should I do?
We will make it better.
All right.
How...
What else?
Now we are the sound...
Sound team!
My dragoons!
My substitute sound team!
What else do I do?
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I am going to...
Okay.
I'll screenshot.
I did everything.
I did minus 45 threshold for the gate.
I turned up my gain.
Should I turn up my gain no more?
Guys?
Can you move the mic away an inch or two?
Okay.
It's away from me.
It's away.
Is that better?
I moved it away from me.
Whoa!
What do you mean, whoa?
Too far?
Whoa!
Hello!
Turn up the gain a little bit more?
Okay.
All right.
Two...
Three...
Okay.
I turned up the gain a little more.
I'm all the way over here!
No, don't leave.
Don't go!
I'm going away now!
Oh!
No!
No, don't leave.
You just need me back!
Okay.
Is this better or worse?
Better or worse?
She's so fine.
I'm fine.
My people need me!
Hi, dragon!
She's better.
All right.
I am further away from the mic a little.
Because sound guy...
Substitute sound team...
Comebacks.
Sad face.
All right.
So, I am a little further away from the mic now.
And my...
You can see that my mouth is turning away from the mic a little.
Because I'm looking at chat.
And there...
I'm...
Now I'm not...
I'm now...
My sound is going towards the mic.
This is me going...
Me looking at my chat while I'm talking.
Um...
Okay.
Is it better now?
How do I sound like?
Is this good enough for...
I can't be good enough!
I refuse...
For it to be good enough!
Okay.
How about now?
We are not doing good enough.
We are doing good.
I demand good.
Not good enough.
I don't care.
No, no, no.
You think you don't care about audio?
Until you watch a stream with very shitty audio.
Then you care.
I'm not getting a mic.
Because if I get a mic...
Okay.
I'm not getting two fucking mics.
So that one mic is the one where it looks at chat.
The other one is the one where I'm looking at my fucking monitor.
Okay.
Why doki sounds so strange?
We're doing tech support with dragoons right now.
I swear to god.
I will bring the...
I swear to god, guys.
If...
If we do not figure this out, I'm bringing my old mic back.
I swear to god.
I will turn this car around and re-plug in my old mic.
I...
Please don't.
I will turn this car around.
I...
This is what happens when you're gone.
This is exactly what happens.
Main sound get chimed in and asked to do this.
Well, he wasn't online when I...
When I wanted to do on stream.
I could have done it yesterday.
But I went to bed.
To be fair, I could have done this yesterday.
I...
So now, we're doing this live with everybody.
Everyone can see the process.
Ben is important.
Okay.
All right, guys.
It's okay.
This is like...
This is a group effort.
When we fix this.
Uh...
When you say really hard...
These and P...
P...
And P's.
We can hear it.
Like...
P...
N...
G...
And...
Purpose.
Being a...
Pussy.
Yeah, we'll do it.
As a...
Team.
Uh...
Together.
Oh, I hear it.
Yeah, it pops.
Um...
Please put up...
No, I do.
I have, like...
Shit sticking everywhere around my room.
But, like...
Obviously, I need more stuff.
I need more...
Um...
Last time I remembered what helped a lot was when I dumped, um...
Plushies around my room.
And it did muffle some things.
Uh...
So, I have to, like...
I guess I just gotta stick more foam around.
The...
The issue about the foam is that it keeps falling off the walls.
So, like...
I'm scared.
I'm scared of, like...
Using anything more permanent.
Because, um...
Because, like...
Uh...
What am I...
What am I gonna say?
Because, like...
I rent this area.
And I'm scared it's gonna rip off.
No, I use the...
The tape.
Like, I use, like, the...
The foam adhesive thing.
But it keeps coming off.
So, like...
I have a couple of, like...
Foam stuff just on the floor.
Because, like...
It all fell off.
And I just...
I was just...
I'm too lazy to stick them.
I...
I sort of low-key just gave up.
All right.
Maybe we stick with the old mic today.
Or stick with us.
And work off here.
So that we can do your settings plus EQ.
All right, guys.
Do we use this mic?
Or do we go back to our old mic?
Do this...
Okay, we'll do a vote.
We'll do a vote.
Okay.
Which mic?
New mic?
We fucked up sound.
New mic with weird settings.
Old mic for the same old jokey.
Okay.
We'll do a poll.
And then from that poll, we're the side.
But this mic sounds good.
Use both at the same time.
I swear you all vote.
I can't handle the awful background noise anymore.
I desire the scuff.
New mic with weird settings.
We're not doing...
I don't have two microphone arms.
Also, do I need a paw filter?
I think that's what...
I don't know what it is.
I don't know what paw filters are.
And what they actually do.
But like, this one has no paw filters.
The paw filter I had when my other mic was like, stuck.
Was like, stuck.
But I don't know what to buy.
There's so many...
Okay, sound guy.
Link me to a paw filter and I'll buy it.
I don't know what to get.
Yeah, I have no paw filter.
It's like naked.
I have a naked microphone.
Sounds crunchy.
Doesn't really do anything.
Just angle your mic.
Paw filter filters that pop.
Like, pussy.
You know, like, pussy cat.
Meow, meow.
Paprika.
What if I...
What if...
Jesus Christ.
Yeah, just raw.
I shouldn't say that.
This microphone is naked and raw.
Pepperoni.
That's my...
Oh, she...
Would you like some...
Pepperoni...
Pizza...
With that...
I'm a...
Dokio...
I'm...
That's what...
That's what the paw sit is for.
Whoa, Dokio...
That's right.
I'm here for unprotected pops.
Yeah.
Me and my...
Naked microphone...
Going in unprotected...
With the...
Pepperoni...
Pizza...
Mamma mia...
Yeah...
I did not expect this microphone to just be streamed.
All right.
Um, okay.
Okay, so sound guy, just send me, send me the link.
We're gonna get some protection for my microphone.
So sound guy, just link me what pop filter I should get.
I don't know.
There's so many different kinds of pop filters, so I don't know which one to get.
So, all right.
New mic with weird settings.
All right.
We'll go with that.
We'll figure this out later.
We'll figure this out.
Ah, the pepperoni, pepperoni.
You know the pepperoni, the no one.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Valvary, thank you for the super chat.
You can try being as Italian as you want, but you all know we crave, we all crave the maid.
Yes, I'll keep that joke up.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Blazing Gun, thank you for the super chat.
But, as promised, a super chat, hopefully you get the settings right on the new expensive-ass mic.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It sounds like she's spitting in her ears.
Yeah!
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oops.
Am I purposely...
...making you un-pumped-a-ple.
Okay, let's play... let's actually, uh, play the...
Let's play the game.
Um, let's play the game.
Alright, I'll stop.
Um...
New microphone...
You go psst, psst, psst, psst, psst.
Alright, new microphone era, guys.
Okay, I'll stop.
Stop fucking with you guys.
It's Tokyo time.
Um...
Is she p-pothering you, queen?
Alright.
You might- Okay, now we play.
Oh, the prince!
Ha ha ha!
The prince!
Okay, wait.
Tell me if the toad voice is a little fucked up.
The prince has accepted our petition to become commanders!
Hope you're ready for a wild battle style!
Ha ha ha ha!
It's even better with the toad voice!
The toad voice sounds better somehow!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Nice.
Alright.
Ha ha ha!
Geo, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Peter Piper picked a peck of pickle peppers!
A peck of pickle peppers, Peter Piper picked!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Okay.
Now, that was the last one.
For real, now.
Guys.
That was the last one.
I won't fuck with you guys anymore.
Ha ha ha!
Ha ha!
For today.
We're..
Bryce, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
The piece delightfully?
Right on my brain inside my skull.
Please, keep going.
Thank you for this super chat!
Thank you!
Papa!
Uh… Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Just checking what it sounds like that for you to say my name with a new mic and your peas.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Uh…
Maybe this was a mistake to put this in the background to sleep, too.
Okay, like, you know exactly what kind of game this is when there are, like, 500 million toads in this game.
Like, there's no way you're trying to go to sleep with toad voice.
There's no way.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, what the heck?
Oh my god, he's here to slam you with his dumpy.
Hey, you go there, yellow Yoshi.
You go.
Do what you want to do.
Alright.
Get this yellow Yoshi out of here.
Okay, Swagoon is dead.
Goodbye.
Oh, Smugoon.
I should've... I was not paying attention to your HP.
I am...
You guys noticed that I wasn't paying attention?
Alright, let's... Let's get...
Okay.
Uh... You know what?
What if I just throw myself?
How fucked up would that be?
Let's see.
Let's get Magnet Bomb in here.
Alright, nice.
Yay!
I realize, like, sound issues is, like, the most prevalent cause of my streams.
I don't know why.
I don't know how I keep fucking up sound.
I don't know.
I've been a...
I've been a streamer for so long.
But yet, somehow, I always keep fucking up my sound.
No matter what.
Yay!
No wonder you need a sound team.
Alright.
Let me...
Let me throw him, too.
I will throw everybody.
Dad will throw everyone.
Alright.
Oh, yeah.
By the way, speaking of sound...
I realized yesterday, when I uploaded...
Jesus Christ, how many fucking things do you have?
Okay.
When I was, like, uploading my Luna Snow video of the, you know...
Dance!
Dance, you fuck!
Yes!
Yeah!
That video...
I realized my music video, no matter what, was in the gaming category for the last couple...
For...
Since it was uploaded.
So then I was, like...
Oh...
I wonder if, like...
I lost momentum because I put it in the wrong category!
It wasn't in the music category!
It was in the fucking...
Oh, wait!
You're evolving!
It was in the gaming category...
The entire time.
So I think...
I think, like, I fucked up the algorithm.
Or, like...
Just the...
The views on that.
It's been a pain trying to listen to it on YouTube.
Oh!
That evolves on the...
KIDU?
Oh, my God!
Lakitu!
Sorry, Lakitu!
That evolves...
That evolves on the Lakitu?
Oh, my God!
Wait!
Now you're actually a good Pokemon!
Come on!
Alright, rock through.
I didn't know that.
That's cool.
Okay.
Lakitu!
Nice!
Okay.
Oh, you can learn more?
It's Barrage.
Oh, no.
That shit's weak.
I only like high numbers.
Yeah, so...
I guess now you can listen to it.
I guess now you can listen to it...
To it...
Um...
On...
Uh...
On YouTube music now.
I think now you can listen to it on YouTube music.
Because I fixed it.
Whoops.
Wait.
Where's my...
Okay.
I'm trying to figure out...
Where's the fishing one?
Okay.
That's the fishing.
I wanted to catch the big fish.
I'm gonna try one more time.
I'm gonna try one more time to catch the...
The big fish now.
Also, I'm trying to figure out how to release music on like Spotify.
I don't know.
I'm too stupid.
I should really ask someone.
I really...
I should really...
You know, I should ask people about that.
I realize I should be doing a lot of things.
Starting today.
I shall be more...
Starting tomorrow.
Or maybe not tomorrow.
Maybe the day after tomorrow.
Starting the day...
Next week.
I shall be more productive.
I...
Wait.
I have a sound team.
Why did I not ask my sound team?
Okay.
But to be fair...
Why didn't they tell me instead of making me ask them?
I...
Do you not have a sound?
Okay.
Now you're just saying random things.
I'm silent.
Starting when I feel like...
You know...
All I'm saying...
Why do I have to ask them?
When they can tell me.
Check out...
Check out this rare creature.
I fished up at the sea.
It's a sound team.
Not...
What the fuck?
Jesus.
He gets to catch that?
I can't catch anything.
Oh shit.
I should not have made him go into that fight.
Whoops.
Oh.
Okay.
I forgot that.
I forgot he's fire type.
Rough skin.
Okay.
He'll live.
Dad will live.
I believe.
I wish it was Pokemon Coliseum time.
And I could just catch it.
Oh wait.
Oh.
Um.
Don't worry.
He'll live.
Oh shit.
The rough skin.
Don't worry.
I can survive.
Oh.
Guys.
It's okay.
I forgot.
I was like.
Don't worry.
He'll live.
And then I realized he has.
It's okay.
I must have one revive here.
There has to be one revive.
Oh.
A one of the kind that revives.
Okay.
There we go.
It's a.
It's a one of a.
Wait.
Is there another?
Do I have any other?
Okay.
Wait.
What?
If I use a rare candy now.
Oh.
I can't.
Okay.
I'm gonna say.
If he levels up.
He'll be back to life.
All right.
Okay.
This.
I need this.
Don't waste it.
It's not a waste if it's towards that.
It's not a waste.
No.
I know it works out of combat.
But I was like.
Maybe it'll be different.
You know.
Like.
Maybe it'll work here.
All right.
Look.
It's time.
You know what to do.
Dragoon.
You know how to end this.
You know exactly how to end it.
All right.
Oh, wait.
Can you learn?
Block?
You don't need that.
I'll attack, baby.
We do our job.
Nice.
Here's your plastic purple coins.
Thank you.
I deserve it.
All right.
Let's go.
Here.
Don't worry.
You like it rough.
On the tongue.
Okay.
Wait.
Get that Yoshi whistle in here.
Oh!
Waluigi!
That's why it's purple coin!
Oh my god.
The actual good character is here.
Woo!
Walking through all this rings sure is exhausting.
All right.
The corner.
Send out the wiggler.
Oh, wait.
Oh, the wiggler's in here!
I love the wiggler!
I wonder if he can, like, get angry.
Finally.
Best character they ever made.
What the fuck?
How did he survive that?
I'm, like, almost 10 levels above you.
I'm literally, like, beating up a child.
All right.
Here you go.
Two times.
That's right.
You ain't doing shit!
Who's that flame whale?
Oh, he gets mad if you crit it?
Oh, that's cute!
That's a cute feature.
I like that.
Also, this egg I brought along of, like, of the child you made is still, like, not hatching.
Like, I don't understand.
How is your egg still an egg?
I've been walking around for so fucking long.
Oh, my God, it's a clef.
It's the iron.
Oh, wait.
I don't know why I put...
I don't know why I put fire here.
It's taking out your dad for the wiggler.
Thank you for the super chat, Absol.
Thank you.
All right.
Surely...
Fighting move is how you kill it, right?
Fucking knew it.
I still don't remember my type advantages, guys.
That's right.
Why the fuck are you taunting me?
If you're just gonna die anyway.
Yay!
I better get out of here!
What?
Purple coins?
Oh, sorry.
Here you go.
Yay, my purple coins.
This here is the recently built Smile Square.
It's supposed to be a symbol of friendship amongst the citizens of Main Street.
But these two ruffians are bringing nothing but bad.
Bad fives.
I don't know what to do.
Who's the ruffians?
They all want to fucking fight me.
So I don't know who's the bad guy.
Hey, Mario.
It's me.
Photo.
Yeah, take a picture.
Yay!
Check me out on Blue Sky.
Okay.
Nice.
I got a damp rock.
It's just...
A rock that...
A rock that has been...
Arena.
Nice.
I can get that anywhere.
No, when can I swim?
Oh my god.
This Yoshi is too fast.
Oh my...
Please.
Let me...
Please!
Okay.
I'm getting off the Yoshi.
I'm sorry.
He's way too fast.
I...
It's so...
It's actually like really difficult to control for some fucking reason.
Oh!
These two ruffians!
No way!
Us Koopas are way better suited for the role.
I mean, have you seen Lord Bowser?
He's called the king of the Koopas.
For a reason.
Power to the people, I say.
And by people, I mean Goombas.
Goombas are just as good as Koopas.
Okay, I'm sorry.
But like...
Is this like...
Is this like a species war right now?
Private Goomba...
Are you listening?
Bowser is called king of the Koopas!
As such, only a Koopa is fit to be a Lord Bowser's right-hand minion.
But Corporal Parpa...
Parpa-Paraplank?
That's just plain unfair.
The majority of Lord...
It's like...
What is it called?
The Reds?
You know like in that musical where they're like through the snaps and it's a turf war?
Oh my god, it's a turf war!
The majority of Lord Bowser's minions aren't even Koopas!
I don't see what's wrong with a Goomba like me taking up a leadership position.
I mean...
Didn't you see Captain Goomba?
Yeah, Jets vs.
Sharks.
Oh my god, this is West Side Story.
And then they're gonna fall in love.
And then they're gonna kiss.
He did a great job leading us minions a while back against Fawful.
Captain Goomba just got lucky.
A minion in the right time and place.
That could have just easily been a Koopa.
Oh, we're getting nowhere with this.
We're Surgeon Guy when we need him to be a tiebreaker.
Hey, wait a minute.
Is that Mario?
You're right!
Come on!
We have to defeat him for Lord Bowser!
Oh my god, this is it!
I am their...
I am their moment where they fight together.
And then like friendship.
And then maybe more.
Wait a minute.
Parablanck!
Look, this is exactly what we needed.
Tokyo can be our unbiased third party.
Really?
I really think we should use this chance to defeat him.
But I also really want to be proven right.
Mario!
What group of minions do you think is more fit to be Lord Bowser's right hand minion?
Koopas, of course, right?
No way.
Koombas for sure.
Right, Mario?
What group of Bowser's minions do you think is the most suited to be his right hand minion?
Alright, guys.
Are we Koopas or Goombas?
I will have to say Goombas are weaker.
Because I can literally just step on him.
I...
Okay.
Valverine, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Papa Smer.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If Doki's being this freaking out Thursday, we'll be epic.
Alright.
Koopas?
I would say Koopas too.
Okay.
Why...
Alright.
Goomba Enjoyers.
Why do you like Goombas more than Koopas?
Please, enlighten me.
Give me your reasons why...
Why you think Koombas are better.
Make your case.
Because they're funny to sabotage Bowser.
Just because it sounds like good.
They're just little guys.
Okay.
But like...
That doesn't mean they're better.
Koopas just have a pleasant shape.
They look like...
Okay.
Like one of them was like...
They have a pleasant shape.
And then someone else in chat was like...
They look like a pee-pee.
Someone in chat said it.
Not me.
Someone else in chat said it.
I didn't say it.
I was just reading off of chat.
I was reading off of chat.
Alright.
I'm gonna say...
I'm sorry.
Goombas...
Goomba Enjoyers.
You did not make your case.
So I will choose the Koopas.
I'm sorry.
But like...
Koopas...
They come in different flavors and colors too.
There's the flying Koopa.
And there's like...
The rest.
There's the flying one.
There's the green shell.
There's the red shell.
And then there's the blue shell.
And then like...
What does Goomba have?
Goomba just wears...
A funny hat.
And then they also like...
Stand on top of each other.
To be a little taller.
So...
I guess Goombas can fly.
But like...
Not as cool.
They're not as cool.
Oh.
Goombas only need...
One form.
Because it's...
Perfect.
But the Goomba stack...
Is just several Goombas...
On top of each other.
Like...
How is that special?
All right.
They're ready to peak specimen.
They don't need improvement.
All right.
Koopa's time.
Ha!
See?
I told you so.
Koopa's reign supreme.
I thought better of you, Mario.
Looks like I have no choice but to fight.
To prove the worth of all Goombas!
Well.
Mario's choice got you a bit upset.
Eh?
Private Goomb?
Don't worry, Mario.
I'm sure Private Goomb will be no issue for you.
I can just step on him.
Why fight him when I can literally just go up and then go...
Ha!
Oh, my God.
He's so sad.
Ha!
Oh, I heard his feeling.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I'm just fighting Goombas?
Oh, that's easy.
Oh, my God.
That's just...
That's just easy.
I'm just fighting other Goombas.
He's...
Look what you did.
He's crying.
I flinched!
All right.
There's no way he can make me flinch a second time.
There we go.
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here.
That's fucking right.
Get him, boys.
All right.
Oh, I can learn...
Oh, I can learn Explosion?
Wait, is that...
That's...
What's that?
Normal.
Inflicts severe damage, but makes the user fade.
Oh, I like...
Ha!
Let me get...
All right.
Let's get through it.
Um...
Let's get away.
Oh, which one?
Ah!
I like that this one always gets a critical hit.
Um...
Glory Accurate.
You're good.
Oh, man.
I don't know.
Okay.
We'll do Vital Throw.
We're getting...
Yeah.
We'll get rid of Vital Throw.
One, two, and...
Poof!
Yeah!
Okay.
Dragoon gained a level 28.
Valvery.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Kick her back, Goomb!
For the glory of all Goomba lovers!
Oh, that's gonna...
Okay.
I'm gonna send...
All right.
Effley, you get in there so you can be fodder for...
You can get hit so I can heal...
I can heal dad.
Don't worry.
Oh, my God.
He...
That's just him, but he can fly.
Is that what he levels up to?
It's just the same guy, but he has wings.
All right.
Do I have anything that heals?
Oh, did I use it all?
God.
Fuck.
Okay.
Wait, no.
I have berries.
Oh, only in battle.
God damn it.
Okay, this is bad.
I don't have any heals.
Uh-oh.
I forgot to buy heals.
That's fine.
I believe in you.
Okay.
This is a little bad when I put it...
Put it all in on dad.
This is a little...
Oh-oh.
Whoops.
All right.
It's okay.
Wait.
I have Ultra Shroom.
Oh, I do.
I didn't see.
Okay.
It's all right.
I'll kill him.
Okay.
I'm just gonna kill him.
So, uh...
Half-Ligoon can still level up.
Nice.
Yay!
Oh, you can get...
Okay.
Oh, I can fly!
Uh, 90.
Let's see.
Let's get rid of Metal Claw.
Because that's a 50 move.
We don't need that.
Yay!
All right.
We gotta swap to another...
Shield.
You know what?
Okay.
No.
I was gonna say you're level 25.
Hi, you're level 25!
Why are you, like...
So behind, everybody?
Okay.
Strolling.
All right.
Let me...
Where's that big mushroom?
Oh, Ultra Shroom.
There you go.
Okay.
Nice.
All right.
That's good.
Go and get...
Go get it, dad.
Okay.
I should really...
Thank God I did not use...
Did not set out dad here.
Because he was...
All right.
You know what to do.
You know...
Okay.
That's...
Oh my God.
Good.
Okay.
That was planned.
That...
That was...
Guys, that was planned.
That was exactly planned.
Don't keep...
Believe me sometimes.
I...
You lick when I tell you to lick.
You never stop licking.
That is the only move that I shall make you do.
She...
She ran the calculations.
Yes, ma'am.
That's right.
Never...
That's the only move you know.
I don't even know why they gave us four moves in general.
Lick, it's the only move you need.
I know.
Don't you know.
All right.
Now we send dad back out.
Oh my God.
Wait.
He has a chain charm?
Oh yeah?
Check out my dog.
You're gonna send a dog?
I have my dog right here.
Jesus Christ.
That's huge.
All right.
Let me use...
What if I just use explosion right off the bat?
That's a big dog.
But...
What is it bigger than this?
Oh shit.
He dug a hole.
Oh my God.
Uh...
Well...
I can't really do anything.
So I'm just gonna throw a random move.
Wait.
How strong is...
Is he weak against...
Is he weak against fighting?
I can't tell.
Let's try.
Oh shit.
It is.
Okay.
Nice.
That's right.
Can't take your way out of this.
Power block.
You were supposed to help me take that Mario.
That's right.
Can't believe you...
This is to all you Goomba lovers out there.
An ant is still an ant.
No way.
How could I lose to you?
For lack of a better phrase.
I told you so.
Koopas are Lord Bowser's most powerful minions.
You'll pay for this, paraplomb.
Our revenge will kill.
What are you gonna do?
A million ants is still like...
It's still just one million ants.
It's like...
It's like the whole one man versus...
One gorilla versus...
A hundred men.
You're like...
One doki versus a million ants.
You'll still not...
You'll still won't win.
I'll just step on all of you.
Bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop.
Thanks for helping prove the might of Koopas, Mario.
Here.
I'll give you this as a way of showing just how grateful I am.
Yay.
Temporary.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Don't expect this sort of treatment from now on, though.
And make sure not to tell Lord Bowser about what happened here.
He died doing what he loved.
Goombing.
Absolute.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I remember, like, someone...
Oh, I should heal.
Someone, uh...
Made a tweet.
Wait, what was it?
Wait, I need to find it.
It was actually pretty silly.
Let me see if I can find this tweet.
I even...
I bookmarked it.
I think...
I don't remember if I liked the tweet or I bookmarked it.
But it was, like, something related to, like, uh, one...
One man versus, like, one...
Oh, yeah.
It's basically, like, uh...
Someone posted a clip of a bug's life.
And...
And they're, like, wow, I didn't realize bug's life got this political.
And then, um...
And then someone in there was, like, It's a metaphor for how a hundred men can easily beat the gorilla.
Because it's the same argument.
It's like...
The crickets or the locusts are, like...
Are, like, we can't let this...
You can't handle a million ants.
Yeah.
But I'm not a cricket.
I'm a grown human being.
I can handle a million ants.
I...
I like how...
It's a metaphor for how a hundred men can easily beat the gorilla.
All right.
Back to our...
Back to Mario.
Finally, we have food.
All right.
Nice.
Yeah, I want to see if there's, like, anything here.
That I haven't caught yet.
Oh, the jabble.
Okay, I know, like...
I know, like...
Okay, but I don't think ants know how to, like, suffocate a...
A human being.
I don't think they're smart enough for that.
Jokey, look up bullet ants and retract your statement.
Not so dead, bullet.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, I'm not...
Okay, I'm not fucking fighting a fucking bullet ant.
I meant, like, the regular ants you find outside your backyard.
Like, I'm not gonna go to the fucking Amazon...
Amazon jungle to fight a million ants.
I'm going...
I meant backyard ants right outside my neighborhood.
You never showered.
Hey there.
Hey there!
Interested in making it to the main trail of pain that arranges some to the guard?
Well, have I got the deal for you!
For just a hundred quons, I'll let you surf across this water here on a Koopa shell!
No need for subsequent payments either.
You can use them as much as you like.
Great choice, mister!
Nice, I got a Koopa shell.
Have fun!
Thanks.
I don't even know when a guard said not let me in.
Oh my god, it's the poison shrewblet!
Alright, let's get him out of here.
He's not worth my time.
Oh, I got a party cap!
Alright, who wants to wear the party hat?
You're almost a town!
Don't give up!
But first, let me beat you up first!
Alright, horned ant.
Oh, speaking of ants.
Okay, if a million ants like wore a fucking helmet.
Oh my god!
They wore a helmet so I can't step on them!
They're evolving!
They turned up the plan!
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Tokyo hands covered in honey versus one million firehands.
The matchup of the year.
Live at the Wrestle...
WrestleTuber SuperSlam.
They bombed.
I can't believe it!
They know the plan!
A million thumbtacks.
Fucking ants.
Can't trust.
Who leaked?
Who leaked to the ants?
My plan!
Who was it?
Was it you Goomba sympathizers?
I fucking knew it!
I knew you Goomba sympathizers would betray me!
She's on to us.
You cowards.
I did it for private Goomba.
That was a great battle!
Yeah!
You're gonna need this if you ever want to make it into town!
This.
You got...
Gotta pay the toll of what it goes through!
Now then, do you have the purple coins right here or not?
420...
Oh my god.
I could have been able to afford it if I didn't pay this fucking...
If I didn't pay him money.
We're anti-Koopas.
Oh my god.
He tried to extort me just now.
Oh well.
Yeah, I could surf now.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
These fucking...
I keep getting stick bugged.
Get Skeetered!
Stop Skeetering me!
Okay, but is there anything here?
Any unique...
Oh!
What the...
Heave Ho?
Oh!
I remember these guys!
Okay, I need something that...
Doesn't kill him.
Alright, you know what to do, Dragoon.
There's no way the Dragoon's gonna one-shot him.
I want to be Ho.
Alright.
There's no what?
There's no way.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god.
He's tossing me.
Oh, he's tossing you guys.
Okay, nice.
I'll just keep licking him.
Alright.
Keep licking!
You know what?
Maybe...
What if I just delete all his other moves?
I just...
I just give Dragoon one move.
And one move only.
Toki, no.
Keep licking!
Alright.
Now we catch.
Toki, please.
NPC, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Toki.
Finished my graduate program.
So, a Toki stream is a nice reward.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And congratulations.
What did you graduate from?
What major was it?
Congratulate...
Don't tell me your university.
I'm not trying to dox you.
I meant like...
I just realized I worded it weirdly.
I meant...
What...
What like...
What major were you graduating?
For it.
I wasn't asking you to dox yourself.
I just needed you to know that.
Congratulations!
I hope you...
Um...
I hope you relax now.
And just enjoy your free time.
After graduating.
Uh...
A machine built to carry and launch heavy objects.
If it seems anyone approaching...
It'll eagerly wait for...
For them to step on...
To send them flying.
And you know what?
NPC!
I will name...
Heepo after you.
To congratulate you.
Okay.
NPC.
Goon.
Alright.
Go to the X-Out box.
You go.
Alright.
Let's see if there's anything else here.
God.
It's so ugly.
Alright.
Let's get out of here.
I don't want him.
It looks fucking weird.
Yay.
Koopa shell.
Oh my...
I can't believe it.
I...
Wait.
Is he rare in this game?
Yeah?
Just do you know.
I've never encountered...
A...
A Pokemon Shiny before.
And that my very first Shiny...
Is in...
Mario...
Come on.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe...
Mario...
What's my first Shiny?
I...
I can't...
Stick bugged.
Stick bugged...
Shiny.
Alright.
What caps do I have?
Okay.
I have this.
I only have...
I can't believe it.
I got...
Stick bugged.
Yay!
I can't believe my first Shiny...
Ever in my...
It is a 1 to...
I can't believe it.
It's a 1 out of...
4,000 chance.
Alright.
I...
Stick bugged.
Wait.
Okay.
Name it...
I'm naming it Stick bug.
I got Stick bug.
I can't...
I like...
I'm like...
Why aren't you...
Why...
Where's your Shiny reaction?
You know like those...
Pokemon...
You know those Pokemon...
Shiny reactions?
And they're like...
Oh my god!
It's a Shiny!
And then I'm just like...
Because I'm disappointed at myself...
That my very first Shiny ever...
Was in Mario...
And it was a fucking...
Stick bug...
I can't...
I can't believe it...
I bought Stick bug...
Even with a Shiny...
I...
No!
This is my first Shiny ever!
Not like this...
Congrats on the Shiny Stick bug...
Alright.
Deserved.
This is part of your history.
My first shiny.
I can't believe it.
Okay.
I'm gonna make sure if there's anything here.
Oh.
What's my luck?
What is my luck?
Nobody forgets their first time.
No!
My first time was a gun stick bite.
Alright.
It's time to lick.
The first times are often filled with disappointment.
Alright.
It's time to lick the mask.
It's okay.
Same shaming.
Oh my god.
It drained.
I can't use anything else.
It's literally like my weakest move.
Okay.
Maybe...
Oh my god.
It's kissing back though.
He likes it.
Okay.
Maybe... I'll try bite.
Bite.
Okay.
Nice.
Not bite.
Maybe like...
I feel like that's just gonna kill him.
I'll try.
Fuck.
No!
Please don't be a rare encounter!
Okay.
You're right.
I should save.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Oh, they're pretty common?
Okay.
Because I haven't found...
You're right.
Alright.
The moment it...
Okay.
We're gonna have to get rid of...
Do we have any water?
We don't, right?
The moment...
The moment this guy hatches...
Then we can get rid...
We can put...
Put him in.
Okay.
Whoa!
Hand fake?
There's so many unique marans here.
Oh, you're right.
I have to reconfigure my entire team.
Ugh!
I don't have like any...
I don't have any weak ones...
For this.
This is a rare...
This is a rare encounter?
Oh!
Okay.
I'll stun it then.
Oh, it doesn't affect him.
Okay.
That's bad.
Alright.
I'm gonna see if I'm...
I'm gonna use a normal ball first...
And see like...
How bad it is.
Oh, nice!
Yay!
I didn't have to do anything!
Alright.
Nice.
Easy.
A black ooze in the shape of a hand.
I'll make a sign of anyone it wishes to become.
Taking its stats and moves.
It loves to finger paint.
Alright.
Who wants to be hand fake?
Who wants to be a giant fucking hand?
Yes, dark type.
Streamer love.
Yay!
Can that be the hand Eon spoon?
Of course you can!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My select.
Oops.
It's just gonna be E.
I almost just made it E.
Yuck.
Alright.
Nice.
Exile!
Okay.
We just need to find the mask guy.
We need the mask guy in our party.
Oh, there he is!
Alright.
Maybe I'll just throw it.
I'm just gonna throw it.
It'd be the goon hand to help out.
Help the team out.
Alright.
Baseball cap.
Ah, thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you!
Let's use another one.
Yeah, the PC box is getting a little freaky.
Alright.
Another boss.
Yay!
I don't wanna do anything!
Alright.
What is his description?
A mask has found guarding treasure.
People seek out areas where it is found.
As riches are known to be lurking nearby.
Wait.
That means there's a treasure nearby.
Alright.
Who wanted me?
Phantos.
Oh, is it Dark Fairy?
Ooh.
Oh my gosh.
I have to readjust my entire party.
It is...
Persona 5.
Oh my god!
No.
I don't think they're gonna release a new persona as long as time.
They gotta milk the last persona game for like 10 more years, guys.
Oh.
They can still milk Persona 5 for 10 more years.
It's just like GTA 5.
Alright, who wants to be the mask?
It's been 8 already?
Yeah, that's what I mean.
On the 20th anniversary, they'll release Persona 6.
Alright.
Me.
Okay.
Do we have anyone named Joker?
Alright, anybody in my...
Name change your name right now to something...
To Joker something or Joker.
And then I...
Any Jokers in chat?
And even me, please.
Name change...
Name change yourself right now to have Joker in it.
So that I can name him Joker Goon.
Genius.
I'm a Joker, baby.
Dude.
If you want...
If you want a Mario mod to be named after you...
If you want Phantoms to be named after you...
Name change yourself right now.
Name...
Name change...
It's my...
Bro, your name is J Gunslinger.
It is not close enough.
I know you can do it.
Are you...
Are you that...
Are you that determined to be the mask?
Name it after yourself.
It's a hard pass.
Then they lose their...
No, that's their new...
It's their new identity now.
And that don't change.
And then we're gonna have like...
10 plus people with that name.
And then they're like...
She named that after...
Oh, there you go.
Joker...
Joker Grad at 2016.
Joker Bros.
This is all for you.
There we go.
Alright.
Joker Goon.
There we go.
We...
Now we have a lot of Jokers here.
This...
This is you, guys.
All you J...
I'm talking about you.
That specific Joker.
Alright.
Nice.
Joker Goon.
Yes.
You.
Right there.
Specifically you.
That I named after.
Not so...
Yes, ma'am.
Joker Goon won.
That's your new identity now.
That's...
Name change just...
For...
Just to be the mask.
Change change just to go in the...
Hey.
It's a cool...
It's a good box.
Alright.
It's a wild box.
You need to sign an NDA if you want to get into this box.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I already have him.
Yeah, you can have fun with John in the box.
Joker Goon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look at that.
All my new Jokers in chat.
All my new Joker Goons in chat.
Dude, that one Joker Goon...
That I specifically named after you...
It was for you.
Just you.
Just remember that.
I named...
All those other Jokers...
It wasn't for you.
It was for you.
Whoa!
Someone else made it all the way out there?
You should take a moment and rest.
We're on 4-2.
It's dangerous if you're not careful.
Good luck out there.
It's chat's Joker art.
Champion!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You wanna know how I got this name?
Oh, 1-Up.
Oh!
Okay, nice.
Oh, yeah.
I should...
Wait, actually, did I just...
Did that just level up?
No, he has just a little bit.
Okay, he just has a little bit left.
Oh, it's a fuzzy!
Okay, I'm gonna catch him.
It's a fuzzy!
It's those little guys on the...
On the...
Like...
Like the rail stuff.
Little chains.
Oh, wait.
I will try one more time.
Absol, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Whoa, looking cool, Joker Goon.
But you look tired after day.
Let's go to sleep.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, I'll do one more.
I lied.
I'm doing it one more time.
I don't think I...
I think I literally have like two more balls.
No!
Fuzzy, just get in my ball!
You get to live your life in the...
Look, I got...
Oh my god, I have one more.
I actually have one more.
I...
Oh no.
I actually have one more cap left.
And it's the party cap.
I fired.
And I fired.
And I missed.
And I fired it again.
Alright, lick time.
It's okay.
I'll just keep licking.
This has to be it.
He's gonna party.
Like 2008.
Join us, fuzzy.
Join us.
Party with us.
Yay!
Okay, I don't have any balls left.
I want to be fuzzy.
You don't have to name change for this one.
Just so you guys know.
You don't have to change your name this time.
Um...
Bug and Dark.
A pest that only gets more annoying with more of it.
Very erratic in nature.
Toads are advised to keep bug spray and a giant boot on them in the summer.
Yeah, it's a little...
It's like a little termite thing.
Alright.
Who wants to be a little fuzzy man?
Wait.
Maybe not?
That'd be fuzzy?
Of course you can, Mike.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I almost just called you just M.
Mike.
Boone.
Into that box you go.
Oh, wait.
It's box two.
Let me readjust that.
Okay.
Uh...
I'm trying to remember how to...
How to get into my box.
Is this.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's change this.
Oh, wait.
No, it should be this.
Yeah.
Uh...
New Pond City.
Seafloor.
River.
Sky.
The beach.
Ooh.
Okay.
How about a cave?
No, you guys deserve to be in a cave.
Name.
Alright.
Okay.
We don't have enough space, but you know what it means.
Wait, wait, you're right.
I could just literally call it.
It's a cave.
It's a...
I have enough space for this, though.
Alright.
Let's...
Uh...
You know what?
Let's customize the Goon Cave a little.
Let's see.
Ooh.
The hand deserves to be in the Goon Cave.
...
Haha.
Alright.
And then...
Let's see.
Who else is...
Oh, yeah.
You'll be in the...
You'll be in that corner, as always.
And then... oh, that tongue, you get to be in the goon cave too.
Let's see...
I think...
Alright, that's good enough.
Alright, nice.
Ricky, stop.
Oh, the fish?
Wait, what, have the fish with the mouth?
Oh, I do.
Forgot about you, pro-goon.
I forgot... you think I forgot about you?
You're lucky all the other dragoons didn't forget about you.
Alright, nice.
Glad I'm still in the exile box.
Now you gotta sign two NDAs.
Black sludge.
But what... what goes over here?
Think you're venturing in a glaring cave?
Be careful.
There's bandits everywhere.
greedy money grabbers.
Pretty money grabbers.
Destroyed just as I saw Mon got...
Wait, do I have...
I don't even remember that.
Soren, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, you're right.
How could I be so foolish?
Where is he?
Oh, wait.
Which one is it?
A pigoon.
Oh, there he is.
That's why he's in the corner.
That's...
That's exactly why he's in the corner right now.
Okay, I don't have...
I don't have any more, right?
I don't have any more caps.
Okay, I should head home.
Okay, we'll come back here later.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know.
Okay.
We'll head back.
And then...
So we can buy more caps.
Okay, I actually don't like this area.
This area confuses me too much.
Okay, I forgot this is the castle.
Whoops.
Toe Town can never fail me.
Bum bum bum ba da da dum.
Oh, wait.
They only have one.
Oh, I need to go to that big mall.
Never mind.
Ah, I'm so stupid.
I have to go to that big mall.
Wait.
Let's see.
The big mall has the better stuff.
But like, I need to remember where the fuck the mall is.
Because it's such a big city.
Where the heck is the mall?
I feel like I have made zero progress.
I've been just...
I've actually been so distracted.
Baseball cap.
First deuce is recruited.
On lower level.
Oh, we should get the party hat.
I feel like we should get the party hat.
They're all so low level compared to me, right?
Or do we get the baseball cap?
It's time to party!
Maybe I'll get like...
I'll get like...
Five.
And I'll get the rest for...
Baseball.
Alright.
That should be good.
We don't need heals.
I believe in dad.
No heals needed.
Warp putt.
And then...
Full town.
GG, no heals.
No need heals.
We're invincible.
I trust in dad.
Yeah, we're not putting the shiny in yet.
Cause I wanna...
I won't wait until I have...
So...
I can use this now.
I can get this.
Yeah!
I wanna...
Uh...
Hatch my egg first before we...
We redo our...
Our party.
Goddamn fucking stick bug.
I gotta go on land.
I cannot deal with stick bug.
I can't...
I still can't believe that's my first shiny ever!
Why?
My very first shiny that I've ever encountered in the wild.
And it had to be a stick bug.
Never had a shot.
Never encountered a wild shiny in Pokemon.
I have to manually get a shiny Eevee so I can have a shiny Sylveon.
Oh my god.
Just fuck it.
Mmm.
Alright.
No, this is the...
This is a new mic.
Bum bum.
What the fuck?
Why would you wanna stay?
Oh, you just wanna give me a kiss.
Mwah.
He's like, no don't leave dad.
Let me give you a kiss.
Okay, now I left.
Alright.
Ooh.
Hey!
I don't recognize you!
Are you gonna see all the gems I found?
Do I go through the cave or do I go up?
Is the cave...
Guys...
Oh, what the fuck is that?
Is the cave part of...
Oh shit, sorry.
I...
No!
Oh no!
Please!
I...
Oh shit!
Oh no!
I...
No!
I didn't mean to do that!
I...
Wait, that's awkward.
That...
That was...
I...
What?
I was trying to ask a question!
I...
I was trying to ask...
That's not...
Oh, that's not good.
Full place.
Let's see how it goes.
I have to go back and...
Ah!
I don't even remember my question.
I don't even remember my question!
I...
I'm so sad.
He has jumped up.
Like...
Oh my god!
What was I trying to say?
I don't remember!
Hey!
Oh yeah!
Okay, so...
Is this part of...
The area where I should be going to?
Or like...
Or is this like...
An inter...
Like...
An intermission?
Because I could go up.
I don't know if I should go up.
Or do I go through the cave?
No, the cave isn't optional.
Okay, but which one...
Okay, you need to go through the cave.
Okay, so...
This...
So...
This is the area where I have...
I can do...
Assortingly welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Sorry, it's...
It's okay.
It happens to everyone on their first time.
Hey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
Marshall, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Even you got learned.
Scared of such strategic genius.
I'm gonna use the path.
I'll be right back.
Still can't believe I did that.
I can't believe it.
I...
I did that.
I forgot what I was trying to say right after.
Like...
Why won't you let me escape?
You're barely in real!
No!
Okay.
Duck, Alan, Ginger, Potipo, Johnny and Mehdi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, I think maybe explosion was the wrong move to learn.
I think...
I think I may or may not have learned the wrong move.
I...
I thought, you know, when I explode, it just will hurt a little bit.
I don't know why.
I...
I just assumed it would just hurt a little bit.
Like, I didn't think it would like...
Cause it wasn't...
Okay.
It wasn't self-destruct.
I was thinking just cause it wasn't self-destruct that I live.
Like, I...
Cause it just says explode.
So like, some people can survive explosions.
Like...
It's just a scratch.
Look, I just...
I didn't see...
I didn't read the fine print.
Okay?
I...
I didn't think I would like, explode it.
Okay, let us...
Let's try...
Using this.
Alright.
Let's...
Let's lick it.
It's the only way to go.
It's the...
It's the only thing I can do.
Just lick it.
Yes.
Oh.
Yeah!
I paralyzed it!
Because it was so good.
Alright.
Get in here.
Plan.
Are you serious?
I spent so much money!
Oh my god!
You're so low level!
I don't understand!
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
We did it.
Yeah!
Yeah, but my party hat is like...
Oh, if he's low level...
It'll be fine.
So I assumed it'd be fine.
Okay, what's cotton spore?
Oh yeah, we don't need that.
You don't need to learn that.
Ah!
Look at your tongue, sir.
Please let our tongue...
No!
In fact!
You're gonna be happy about it.
No!
Vav...
Goon...
Wait, actually does...
Does your name fit?
Where's V?
A-L-R-Y...
No, it doesn't.
I'll just call you...
Vav Goon.
Alright.
No!
You're gonna be...
You're gonna enjoy it!
In fact!
Go!
You're gonna enjoy it in the goon cave!
That's right!
Toki, please!
You're gonna live in a goon cave now!
Because of how happy you are!
What the fuck?
What...
Did...
Did cancer happen?
How did he become three?
What happened?
How did they multiply?
I'm scared!
Mitosis!
Oh!
We fixed it!
Nice!
We fixed him!
Alright!
Yay!
It's a wish...
Oh!
It's a wishy-washy ability!
I was like, what the fuck happened to him?
How did...
Aw, man!
I wish...
I wish dad could get these levels right now!
Aw,
this sucks!
Alright!
I'm gonna do it!
I'm gonna use her...
Wait!
Was he leveled up?
Let us continue...
Like, until we can go no longer!
Not so joker-kun!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Yay!
Oh, you're just a regular guy!
Hey!
I'm not just a regular guy!
I am...
Tokyo!
I'ma check him, like...
No, he hasn't!
God damn it!
He didn't level up!
Aw...
Fuck!
Okay, that sucks!
Okay...
Anything here?
Let's see if I...
Oh, it was just to grab this item!
Alright...
The moment I grab this item, we...
Uh...
TP back!
Okay...
Nice!
And that's it?!
Ivan, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Doki bird!
Yeah?
What about Doki bird?
Ha, ha, ha, ha!
Ha, ha, ha!
It's...
Ha, ha, ha, ha!
Ha, ha, ha!
That's me!
Ha, ha, ha, ha!
Oh, I forgot about that guy that randomly is!
Ha, ha, ha!
That's me!
True...
I was like, what did I do?
Jokey bird.
I think he, like, accidentally clicked send and forgot to type the rest of his message.
That's deep, bro.
Oh my god, I could have healed him.
I denied dad some XP.
Because I got confused.
Can I move this yet?
No, I didn't.
Oh, it's Bandit!
Jordan's sad story.
Alright.
It's time to lick.
That's right.
Dragoon.
Rice, thank you for the super chat.
Lick time!
Lick him!
Lick him until you can't no more!
Keep licking!
He does nothing to you!
Lick!
Oh my god, a critical hit, too.
Meow.
That's right!
Lick!
That's the only move you know.
And that's the only move you'll use.
Next scene, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
How do you miss?
He's right there!
Oh my...
Oh, it's because he used sand attack.
He actually used pocket sand on me.
Don't worry.
Eventually, you'll hit.
There's sand in our eyes.
There you go.
I knew you could do it.
My pocket sand.
Ba-dump, ba-dump, ba-dump.
Yeah!
Alright, who wants to be a bandit?
Alright, Ifen.
You get to be bandit.
The one that got licked the most.
A shy guy who steals things.
Its mask shows a permanent sneaky grin.
It is believed that half of all petty theft reports are caused by bandits.
Soren, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You get to be in the goon cave too.
JD, welcome to tomato fire.
Welcome, welcome.
I-fing gooon.
They have all licked you.
Anson, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Every mod I've captured so far has been licked.
Come on, let me out of here.
Yeah, yes, it's like a taste test.
Well, I know he tastes good.
Bro, okay, if you want to fight, okay.
Okay, you want to fight, okay.
Okay, I won't use the explosion.
The mark of the goon.
He saw what the other bandit was going through and he wanted...
He's like, come on!
Let me be part of it.
Let me be part of it too.
It looked really fun.
He saw what iPhone went through and wanted to join in.
Okay, I leveled dad up too.
Since I just leveled him up in general.
He's like, it should have been me!
Oh, that's cute!
Look at him!
Dang.
Alright, get in here.
A small bat!
Look.
Look at those eyes.
He saw.
What I did.
He tried to protect himself, but you can't protect yourself from this.
Oh, Zero!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
They couldn't pass it to the whole class.
Alright, who wants to be...
Who wants to be Fang?
A rotund bat.
It favors damp caverns.
It flies in elaborate patterns and leaves behind delicate air currents that resemble dotted lines.
Let's see.
Doki bird is the word.
Bye!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Uh...
Not me!
Not like me!
Okay.
Man-goon.
I liked your comment.
You get to be Fang.
You've seen things.
Man-goon.
Into the goon cave you go.
Oh, I got Big Nugget.
Alright, I leave.
I saw.
Joker, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh!
Pushed me away?
Oh, I can't go here.
Okay, so I have to go this way then.
Oh!
Item.
We won.
We run.
Oh, more money!
I like money.
Yay!
Oh, there's another bandit.
Alright, if they won't let me...
I wonder if they, like, let me get away.
Oh, they do.
Some of them do.
That other bandit was, like, fucking freaky as hell.
The other bandit won't let me go.
You saw what I did to the first one.
This one was, like...
No, don't go.
I wanna...
I wanna be in the box, too.
Alright.
Yeah, that one bandit was a freak.
I had to beat him up.
I had to, like...
Oh!
Wait, that has to be a rare encounter.
I've never seen him before.
I haven't seen him other than on a trainer.
Alright, Dragon.
You know what to do.
Star bag!
You'll be fine, right?
Oh, you're fine.
This time.
Lick.
Yes!
Lick the bag!
He's not wearing socks, too!
Alright.
We'll use the ball cap.
Oh!
Oh, what?
He's like...
No!
He got lead!
That's so fucked!
Marshall's thinking...
He didn't pay!
He didn't pay for the services!
We saw...
We saw we were too freaky.
He said, nah.
What's going on here?
Oh, you...
No, wait, wait.
Oh, wait.
I swear to God.
Look, he...
He enjoyed it!
I swear to God!
Absolutely.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nothing personal, kid.
Officer!
Please!
It wasn't me!
Alright.
Get him out of here.
Even the half's judging.
Ooh.
What's this?
I'm so sad!
We didn't get to catch him!
Officer, I swear to God.
He liked it.
He's the one that scammed me!
I gave him two free licks and then he ran away.
Licked for free and left.
Lego, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He scammed you guys!
Dragoons!
You were the ones that did it!
What?
I was just...
I was just making it.
You guys do it.
Alright.
Get out of here, Ironcliff.
Okay.
Wow charge.
Boom!
Okay.
Oh, that was a lot of XP!
Yay!
Agility.
You don't need to be fast.
Hahaha!
No.
Yes.
Oh wait, I keep pressing action press.
No.
Yes.
You don't need to be fast guys.
I guess if you're here, then either the guard outside let you in, or you came from 4-2.
Oh well.
I lost fair and square.
So here's your purple coins.
Yeah.
You're here to enjoy it.
You don't need the speed for that.
Here we go.
This way.
Marshall, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We don't need money.
We do it for the love of the game, Toki.
Alright.
Does Marshall speak for all you dragoons?
I just want to be sure.
Does he...
Does he speak for all of you guys?
Portobello.
Wow there!
We'll let you in!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We saw his feet for free, so that's even.
No, no, no, no.
Alright, nice.
Oh, they sniff it!
Alright, time to throw him.
Get outta here!
That's right!
Yay!
Oh no, they're catching up to dad.
We can't let that happen.
Nice.
100 coins.
Oh, another nugget!
We're gonna sell these nuggets to buy more caps.
Nice.
Star piece.
Christopher!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Toki.
First time super...
Oh my god, he's a shy guy!
First time super chatted.
Please know I adore your Carmen-coded voice!
Wait, do I actually sound like Carmen?
Oh my god.
Alright, it's time.
Lick.
No!
Why won't you let me lick?
Hahahaha!
Alright.
He hates it.
I can't believe it!
Yami, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe it!
He's normal.
He's immune.
No!
What's the point?
Oh, I only have two caps.
Oh, I only have two caps!
I don't have anybody that's fucking weak!
Lick was my weakest move!
It was actually my weakest move!
Okay.
There has to be one that's weaker.
Oh no, I put it all in Lick.
I put it all in Lick.
Oh!
I feel like I'm just gonna slap him if I use...
No, he can't!
The last time I used headbutt!
He fucked...
Oh wait, let's see.
Alright.
Maybe bite.
Let me check, let me double check.
No scheme!
No, it's 60.
Okay, I'll send out...
I swear to God, if...
If you kill him, I swear to God, I'm sending you...
Smug goon, if you kill him, I'm sending you into the goon cave.
I'm
sending you into the goon cave!
Into the goon cave, you go!
Alright!
Any innocents, please!
It's stick bug time into the goon cave.
You did nothing wrong.
I had one simple instruction.
One simple instruction.
He was just... I told you to use a fine whip.
It's too late.
It's time to goon in that cave.
Oh my god, there's like two mons that I want to catch in here.
Oh, there he is!
One of them!
Okay, nice.
Nice, okay.
Okay, we still have a chance.
Tree, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Back for more.
Time.
That's right.
I'm back.
Alright.
Got you this time.
Yay!
That's right.
You gotta pay for this.
Yay!
Sick bug grew to level 12.
Struggle bug.
What are you struggling?
You don't have to pay rent.
Alright, scary face.
I was like...
How are you struggling?
A walking bag of star bits that's easily startled.
It has the ability to learn turn invisible when frightened.
I still know how many of them exist in the world.
Alright, who wants to be a star bug?
Or star bag?
He has to pay rent by fighting for his...
Yeah!
I have to pay for it!
Pebble, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, Absol.
I'll give it to you.
Absol...
Oh, wait.
Coon.
There we go.
You're the freak.
Wait.
You should be...
Also, your Yoshi impression was so cute.
Baby Kwan!
Thank you for the super chat!
Ah!
You were just a little too late.
Don't worry.
I got the next one for you.
Okay.
Gotta go here.
Obviously, he's watching.
So, he should be, like, in the center.
And then, like...
Um...
We'll put...
Whisp Goon over here.
So, like, he's at the top.
And then...
Smogoon.
You're gonna...
You...
You get assigned to...
Naso Goon.
And then...
Vav Goon.
You get assigned the hand.
And then...
Here we go.
There we go.
There...
Oh, wait.
Obviously, it's here.
There we go.
So, here are all your assignments.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
So, he isn't...
Goon...
All right.
So, Smog, you get not-so...
Goon.
Yeah...
Um...
Wait a minute!
Not-so Joker...
You have...
Oh, wait.
That's fine.
The Joker Goon is, we're like...
More than just one...
One...
It wasn't... Okay, um, we have Abso with Wisp Goon, Aifen with Pro Goon, um, Fav Goon with Eons Goon, and then our Watchers, Matt... Okay, you get this corner, and then Dick Goon, you get the other corner.
There we go.
The perfect Goon game.
Um, Abso, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't keep casually writing.
All right.
It's perfect.
Okay, we just need Shy Guy.
We literally just need Shy Guy.
And then we should be good to go.
Champion, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, stop giving me bandits!
I can't... This is all your fault, Smug.
This is... This is... This is your fault.
You used Gust.
That's why you're vanished into the cave.
You know what you did!
You used Gust!
You used Gust and killed him!
It's okay, one cap to get it done.
We got this.
I believe in the one cap run.
It's so true and so real.
Please!
I want the Shy Guy!
Oh!
He was the rare encounter!
You could have missed!
Oh no, I went the wrong way.
Whoops.
Huh?
I didn't get into clearing cave!
No way!
You brave for it too?
Ha!
This ruins my entire plan to make some quick cash!
Okay.
Are you... No, this was the cave...
This was the way I saw Shy Guy.
Right here.
Let me have...
Let me have my Shy Guy!
I want Shy Guy!
He was so cute!
Oh my god, I can't believe...
Guys, can you encounter him in any other areas?
Or is this the only area?
That's right.
I deleted his small business.
I'm here to franchise.
He's just a Shy Guy.
No, I have one cap to get the job done.
He's also in Peach's Castle.
Okay, I didn't see him in Peach's Castle.
So he is a rare encounter.
God damn it!
He's a rare encounter!
That fuck, he sucks.
Okay.
I swear...
Okay, I'm gonna do it...
If I don't see him in the next five turns...
If I don't see him in the next five encounters...
I'm...
I'm giving up.
Alright, four.
There's an uncapped frame rate button on my...
Wait, really?
No, we don't need that.
Alright, three.
I lost count.
Wait, two?
How did I lose count already?
I lost count.
Okay.
One.
Okay, one more.
He's very shy.
Why are you shy?
It's still three, guys.
It's still three.
Oh my...
Okay, it's over.
Goodbye, Shy Guy.
I guess I'll never see you.
Unless...
I'll do one more Hail Mary.
I'll do one more.
I'll reset it here.
2.5.
2.4.
2.3.
God damn it.
I don't think I encountered Shy Guy in the Peach's Castle.
In the garden.
I had trouble encountering him.
What has Main Street become?
This cave used to be free for anyone to enter.
But ever since Waluigi showed up and bought all the land, they've been greedily trying to tunnel through to the other side.
All I want is to go back to the days where I could explore this cave freely.
How dare you say that about our boy Waluigi?
I can't believe it.
How dare he?
Waluigi would never!
This bush has been activated.
I've been acting very strange ever since my friend from Sarasaland gifted it to me.
Every time I trim it, it seems to grow back immediately.
Can you give me a look?
Okay.
The wild Pokey leaped out to attack?
What's this?
Hmm.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Oh, this is for my one ball.
Alright, Pokey.
Alright.
This is it.
It's time.
Wait.
You might die.
But it's time.
It's always time.
Lick the cactus.
Wait.
Toki.
No.
Oh.
Your final breath.
The last thing you do.
This is...
He died doing what he loves.
Changed the world.
Guys.
Lick the crow says, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guy gets shy around cute girls.
Finally, we are free.
Soren, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, how much damage does this do?
Jesus Christ.
I wonder if like...
Uh...
It is raining.
Alright, how much does bug bite do?
Oh, nice.
Okay, just enough.
Guys.
Alright.
Got one ball to catch him.
Wait.
Actually, to guarantee it, let me just...
Okay.
Goodbye, stick bug.
To catch one guy, he has killed like...
Two of my mons.
Okay.
Oh, it doesn't affect him.
Okay, that's fine.
Alright.
This is it.
It's time to party.
Pokey was caught!
Oh, that koala wanted to beat you.
Alright, nice.
A walking cactus.
Its body segments are not vital organs.
It sheds them every two years.
It has a wobbly demeanor and uses a silly face to lure in young prey.
Alright.
Let's see.
Koala...
Goon.
There we go.
That's kinda dark.
I mean, well, don't fucking lick cactuses.
Alright.
Into the exile box you go.
I should...
I should have known a poke was hiding in there.
Well, thanks anyway.
For taking care of it.
Now my bush can be trimmed properly.
Yeah, I did it.
I'm such a good person.
Okay, there's the defense bean.
Hello, are you okay, sir?
I hear the reason Waluigi even bought this part of Main Street was because the cave had some serious money making potential.
Although, I don't think Waluigi even cares too much about the money in the first place.
All he wants to do is expand his operation and become the ultimate gamer.
Whatever that means.
What?
Of course...
Waluigi, you want to be the ultimate gamer?
Let's go.
That's my Oshii.
Even Waluigi with all his money was at trouble developing the land past this point.
Be careful you're planning on hating out there.
My hero, Waluigi.
Wah!
My Oshii right there.
Wanting to be an ultimate gamer, I can relate.
Alright, let's restore him.
Yeah, don't you dare disrespect my homie like that.
Not so, Joker.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I gotta get out of this kingdom soon.
There's weirdos everywhere.
I heard that 90% of gamblers strike big before they quit...
Shut the fuck up, Shy Guy.
Shut the fuck up.
I tried.
I tried to catch him.
How did he know?
I tried!
There's a lot of bad people around Main Street.
Keep yourself safe.
Whoa!
Toad.
Damn, that's fucked up, Toad.
Whoa!
Bro!
I didn't know there was worse influence than Bowser.
Waluigi.
Gamer Toad!
Whoa!
Toad!
That's fucked!
Keep yourself safe now.
Main Street used to be a small little village in the marshes.
Then, Waluigi came and built that foreign casino.
Now all people can think about gambling away their coins.
Wait, I don't wanna win purple coins.
Purple coins are so shining and sparkly and purple!
Everyone's so keen on the new purple coins.
I'm not really too crazy about them.
But they practically replaced our entire economy!
Wait, so they're like the British pound.
Versus euros.
What am I going to do?
Oh, sorry!
I didn't notice you!
I'm just worried about my son!
I haven't been able to focus, lady!
You see, he went east to work on clear and claim a while back.
And fell into these nightmares shortly after!
He hasn't woken up since!
And I've been worried sick!
Please!
You have to do something!
What the fuck do I do?
It's the only clue I have about what happened!
What's done?
No!
Please!
The fuck do I do?
Get a doctor!
I'm just Italian!
Like...
Why won't she just get a doctor?
Waluigi told us to go earn our keep at the Casino Red and pay us up front!
What kind of solutions is that?
Just send us a gamble for the work we did!
Main Street, I've really been booming lately!
Okay, there's too many toads.
I'm... a cat.
Thanks to Waluigi bring over purple coins!
Although it is a bit weird having a different currency from the rest of the world!
There's too many toads!
I hope Waluigi ends up paying us what we're owed for the working glittering cave.
We need our purple coins!
I'm gonna give my toad voice a little rest, or it was just too many.
It's like 90% of this population is just fucking toads.
Oh, hello there!
Are you looking for the casino?
I'm sorry to say, but that's not in this building.
You gotta head on down to the far end of Main Street if you wanna find it.
Okay.
I only recently moved to Main Street after I heard about the brand new casino!
I'm gonna strike it out and get rich quick!
As soon as I take out a small loan from the guy on this floor.
That is...
Oh, it's a loan shark!
You here to see the boss?
Be on your best behavior, you hear me, pal?
You better not get on the boss's bad end side.
Otherwise, we'll have to come after you.
And I mean it.
You need some purple?
Talk to the boss, then.
And don't be disrespectful.
What the fuck?
Some purple?
Holy shit!
This is so...
This sounds illegal.
Marshall, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Puberty Hit Boy Stone's voice like a truck.
He's some purple kid.
What's that?
You're here to get some purple coins?
Well, you're in luck, friend.
I'm willing to loan you some.
No need to fill out an application or anything.
Heh!
So what do you say?
Trust me?
He seems like a nice old man, guys.
Smart choice, friend.
Got five!
Oh my god!
I'm rich!
A thousand!
Oh, I'm going to the casino.
I'm ready.
I'm gonna go to the casino.
I'm gonna make it big!
This is it!
Don't tell anyone.
The building right behind has an infamous...
Oh my god, why didn't he tell me sooner?
No, Shrike.
I heard Bowser borrowed some purple coins from him the other day, only to find himself frizzled and dead.
I will stay clear.
Why did you tell me now?
I just borrowed purple coins!
Why did he tell me this now?
Pulo's like, these are all that are left of what Main Street was before.
While Luigi set up his casino.
This used to be a place of nature.
But I suppose this is good for business.
No!
Why did he not say this sooner?
Oh my god, I can spend it all...
on hats!
Guys!
I can spend it all...
I can buy 99...
I'm gonna buy 99 baseball caps!
I'm gonna do it!
Let's go!
Are you sure?
And you...
Faith, and you wanted 99?
Are you sure?
Yes!
I'm rich!
I have 99 hats!
Guys!
I'm rich!
I just lost all my purple coins in the casino.
Now I gotta live in the mar with my pro.
Guys!
I made a great financial decision!
I have so many hats!
It's basically free money, guys!
Absolutely!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Toki's inner team fortress 2 player unleashed!
The new main street is great!
Thanks to Waluigi's casino, I can afford anything I want!
Sure, I may have gotten just a bit lucky!
I found a nice man who loaned me a whopping 5,000 purple coins!
Instead of gambling win, I used the funds to rent out a nice flat!
Uh...
Where I can live out the rest of my days in peace!
What's this?
Whoa!
Sorry, I got...
I got, like, a voicemail because I ignored a call.
HAHAHAHAHAHA!
HAHAHAHA!
And so I was like, what's this?
Is it an important call?
HAHAHAHA!
Oh well!
Alright!
It's the lone shark!
Oh no!
Huh?
Don't bother me!
I'm busy playing Super Mario Bros.
3 Gacha Edition!
You used purple gold?
No!
Gacha Edition!
Oh no!
Not the...
Not the transactions!
Not pay to win!
Hmm...
Only had some viruses to test these pills out on.
But the prices at the casino are much too steep for me.
No!
Not the microtransactions!
I live with maniacs.
One of them is addicted to pills.
And the other gacha games...
Our purple coins aren't going to last long at this rate.
Oh hey!
What is he doing here?
What?
Ever seen a Magikoopa besides comic before?
We exist, I assure you.
Not everyone is a die-hard fan of Lord Bowser.
Though...
I probably shouldn't be talking to you now that I think about it.
We're supposed to be starting a minion support group here.
But doesn't seem like many of Lord Bowser's minions are even aware of us.
Oh my god!
A minion support group!
Luke, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Now I see how she spent 200k in one year.
It's 99 hats!
Guys, I swear I can pay him back.
You know what?
I feel so confident.
I'm gonna save too.
I'm gonna save after purchasing 99 hats.
What for this?
Honey there.
Want some max nut?
I'll cut you a deal for a doorway.
You know what?
Let's grab one max nut.
Here's your max nut...
Now straight from the source?
Hello, police?
Okay, wait.
Wait a minute.
What is a max nut?
Oh, okay, okay.
It restores HP.
Okay, it's a peanut, guys.
Guys, it's not... It's a peanut, guys.
It's a peanut.
But, like, where did he get it from?
Like... Oh, no, he can't talk.
Are you okay?
Did you get a concussion?
Do you need a doctor?
Don't worry, I'm Dr. Mario.
Oh, no, this Koomba can't talk.
Koomba, are you okay?
Oh, my God, you finally hatched!
It's been 80 years.
Whose child was this again?
Whose child was this?
I forgot who the parents were.
That was how long ago it was.
John and Mehdi?
All right, what do you want to name your kid?
Who was the mother?
Who was...
All right, John's the ma or is it Mehdi?
All right, what do you guys want to name your child?
Jedi.
Jedi, good.
Mehdi, don't be ashamed.
I know you guys are here.
Don't be ashamed right now.
This child is not mine.
I demand a DNA test.
John, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, all right.
Jedi, goon.
Okay, John, you are not the father.
I don't know.
There were only two of you there.
All right, Jedi, goon.
Jedi, goon.
There you go.
You're right.
You're not the father because you're the mother.
Congratulations.
It's a boy.
All right, now we can put the baby in the chamber.
All right, you have to be in the exile chamber, though.
All right, and then I want to...
No, it's too late, Mehdi.
It's too late.
Mehdi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Absolute.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
John, you are the father.
Oh, yeah, I want to bring the ghost in.
Okay, I want to rearrange my team.
Okay, this one is...
Steel, fly, and then grass, dark.
Normal, steel, fly, grass, dark.
Bug, water.
And then we have ghost.
Okay, steel, fly, grass, water, fighting.
I don't know, actually.
I actually think my team is fine so far.
You know what?
Yeah, we'll keep this team.
I like this team.
Awesome.
Yeah, I like this team so far.
I hate this PC so much.
I was loading that super chat for a full minute.
We were too late, Mehdi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What's that?
You're new to the casino?
Here, take this.
Don't expect this sort of kindness from the other patrons, though.
Feel like they have to battle them if you want any purple coins.
Good luck out there, my mustachioed friend.
Wait, let's go gambling.
Oh my god, it's just like the Pokemon version.
Okay.
Oh my god, this is a lot harder.
Oh my god, wait, I can do this.
Okay.
Yay!
Okay, nice.
Okay, I figured it out.
Fuck.
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
No!
Oh, nice.
Okay, we got two.
Okay, we got some of our money back.
Okay, this is really hard.
I should quit the game.
Seems you're too distracted to notice you.
Well, I can't stop winning.
Oh, shit.
Let's go gambling!
Aw, dang it!
Wait, he can't stop winning.
So like, maybe I'll be lucky too.
And press...
Okay.
And then we go...
Green Yoshi.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I said green Yoshi!
I'll keep playing.
Green Yoshi.
It'll eventually hit green Yoshi.
Oh my god, we are so close.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay.
Green Yoshi.
No!
You...
Okay.
Purple Yoshi.
All the purples!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you kidding me?
Purple Yoshi.
No.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I have one more.
Green Yoshi.
I swear to god.
Are you...
Oh my...
Okay, I need to use the bathroom.
I...
It's fine.
Alan, Medi, Zekra, Bike, Ghost, Solid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's okay.
It's fine.
All right.
Green Yoshi.
Eventually, I'll hit green Yoshi.
I believe.
Okay.
Yellow Yoshi.
Okay, that's fine.
Getting rid of...
Wrong color.
Green Yoshi.
That's okay.
It'll hit.
Guys, trust me.
It will hit.
Oh my fucking god.
Don't worry.
Green Yoshi.
No.
I made it all back.
I made everything back.
I told you.
Eventually, it'll hit.
Oh, it was just 12.
Okay.
We stopped there.
We might have to stop there.
I don't...
Hey, have you checked out the prizes?
They're even offering up some party members.
Doesn't feel very legal.
Oh, I can exchange.
Okay, there's the...
Oh, I already have that though.
That's the...
Little Sparky.
Mecha Koopas.
Virus.
Oh!
Oh my god.
I should have...
Okay, we're gonna...
It's $1,000 for 50 coins.
Wait, 500 coins for $10,000.
Oh, I can exchange stuff.
Is that it?
That's like a cold drink after a win at some slots.
Okay, where does this go?
Oh.
Oh, is this a puzzle?
Mario Minecraft.
Can you please come here for a moment?
This is your first visit a casino, correct?
Do you have a coin case?
Oh, you already have a coin case.
Now then, allow me to explain the rules of casino.
Waluigi, who runs this casino, believes in the philosophy of a rich gets richer.
This means in order to progress further...
Oh my god, he's just like...
He's just like us, guys.
To the machine with better odds, you need to already have quite a few purple coins.
Purple coins can obtain through any means necessary throughout both Main Street and this casino.
You're not just restricted to gambling in the slots in here.
Use your intuition to figure out the best way to acquire purple coins and make your final room with Waluigi.
Only those capabilities are worth his power stars.
Alright.
Oh, it's this puzzle.
Wee!
Oh, hello.
I'm gonna hit it big.
Just you wait and see.
Hmm.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So all of these are like...
So the further I go, the more...
I need to make sure I don't use that.
The better the odds are.
Alright.
Oh, that's super effective.
Okay.
It's not very effective.
Flame wheel.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
He started clapping.
That's all I can do now.
I got too happy.
I want to meet my Oshi.
Wah!
Luigi.
Yay!
Stick bug.
You go, stick bug.
Marsha, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If any means necessary, I guess we'll have to do some more.
Oh, my God.
The stick bug can bite?
Okay.
60, 50.
40, uh...
We'll get rid of the quick attack.
Casual, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Well, speaking of Elder Ring, isn't that tomorrow?
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Explosion looking at Doki like the green goblin mask.
He's like, Pick me.
Who know you want to, Doki?
I'm right here.
I...
Come on, Doki.
Click me.
Oh, I used to...
Oh, wait.
No, it's fine.
I was still clapping.
Yeah, that was 16.
Oh, my God.
Dead!
We're gonna evolve to.
Oh, my God.
We're gonna evolve into the bomb...
The bomb king.
It only makes sense, right?
Wait, is it?
That's the king, right?
Yes!
He grew into the king, Ba-bam!
Oh, my God.
He's so dapper now.
He's still firefighting.
Why are you firefighting?
He's...
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha...
But, like...
What if I...
What if I have to use... Lord live the game.
Okay.
Oh yeah, you're right.
It is better.
You're right.
I should... No, we keep it.
Alright.
I learned fire punch.
He's gonna punch his problems away.
I was doing so well.
Rules are rules.
What's this?
Pay a hundred dollars?
It's a coin.
I'm not gonna fucking pay a hundred dollars.
What the fuck?
Okay, but like, is this easier now?
Okay, no it's not.
I'm not gonna pay a hundred dollars.
Fuck that shit.
Where does it take me though?
Okay, I should pay a hundred dollars.
Okay.
You guys, I might have to pay a hundred dollars.
All right.
This should be the right one.
Yeah.
Oh, now I have better odds.
Green Yoshi.
Would the lone shark take my night?
They said I have better odds!
They lied to me!
Whoa!
Mario!
How'd you get here so fast?
I just destroyed that warp pipe.
I mean, those toads work fast on repairs, huh?
Never mind that.
Gamec!
I need you for Mario!
Buck kicking time!
Be right there!
You're gambling this!
You know what?
Take your time.
Maya!
Back-to-back butt-kicking time!
You think he'll loan me 5,000 purple coins?
You think he'll loan me that money?
If I take a loan from him, then I can use it to pay back my other loan.
And then I'll take another loan from someone else.
So I can take back that, so that I can pay this loan.
And then I'll just have to keep taking loans.
And then it'll be fine.
Okay, he grew level 17.
Nice.
The infinite money glitch.
Alright, he's gonna send his, like, subject in.
Fine.
That's...
It's not fine.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Oh, shit.
I never even thought I had to get this...
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Guys.
Wait, what do you mean it wasn't fine in the end?
It was no longer fine.
The king!
Law live!
Wait, do I have...
Oh, nice.
I knew it.
Nice.
Okay, he's back.
Don't worry.
Dad's back.
Can't keep him down.
What the fuck?
How do you still have critical hit?
Is this all you know?
Alright, nice.
He's down.
Okay, nice.
Now 31.
Stick bug with a level 18.
Oh, he learns this...
No, we don't need that.
Okay, Mecha Koopa.
Okay, it's time.
It's time for you to throw a robot.
Oh!
I love those things.
They're so cute.
Get out of here.
That's right.
You can't keep the king down.
You're so goofy.
I know.
Shadow sneak?
What is that?
Then use your shadow to strike first.
Oh, nah.
We don't need that.
That's a weak- Weak-ass move.
Alright.
That's okay.
We have this.
We don't need quick attack, guys.
We don't need it.
Okay, nice.
Oh, he doesn't do critical hit on him.
I just noticed that.
There can only be one king.
It doesn't matter.
I just need one hit.
Yay!
Oh.
My other two little guys are gaining so fast.
Kamik!
Your strategy didn't work!
Stickbug is evolving!
What does he evolve to?
I don't remember.
Oh my god.
The fuck is he...
What's that?
What is that?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, it's a scuttlebug!
Oh my god.
The purple looks so weird.
Okay, vacuum wave.
Wait, is he fighting?
I swear to god.
I swear to fucking god.
Nah.
I mean...
Hahaha.
He stole Bug water?
Oh.
Hahaha.
I was like...
I swear to fucking god.
Are you...
Alright.
No, we don't need that.
Oh!
Double kick!
Wait, he has like so many...
We don't need that.
Why do I keep losing?
Take your stupid purple coins Mario.
Do you have like 4,800 more?
I sort of need a little bit more.
No, no, we don't need priority moves.
We just need Ungabunga.
You and I are going to have a serious talk about these strategies.
Now, is it this tile or... No, it's okay, guys.
We just need Ungabunga.
That's it.
Where are the other?
Okay.
I believe.
Okay, never mind.
I don't believe.
We Unga until we Bunga.
Oh, hey!
Oh, this battling for purple coins has really tied me out.
I'm glad at least I don't have to use the slots.
Wait, you guys said I can like... Uh...
Use some of your purple coins on this.
It'll heal your potty right up.
You said you got... We can like change how we throw the ball?
Okay.
How do we change it?
All green, by the way.
Oh, my God.
I fucking knew it.
Oh, I hit it.
Nice.
Oh, it has a pattern.
Oh!
Alright, guys.
How do we cheat?
Hey!
I was in a...
Oh, no.
She's addicted.
My three whole coins.
Okay, Fire Punch might be good against this.
Also, it's funny that you guys think that I'm ever gonna send Sick Bug out.
You guys are like, No!
Stop!
You need priority!
As if like, he's ever gonna come out and actually fight.
He's like more...
Oh, shit!
High critical.
Wait, I can...
That's better than Storm Throw.
Oh, but it's only five moves.
Okay, I need to stop hurting myself.
I'm gonna get rid of Wild Charge.
I feel like...
Me hurting myself is like...
We gotta stop that.
Oh, no.
Yeah, my team is just him.
Oh, I don't have any.
You know what?
Let's try.
Let's get him out of here.
Wait, what?
Oh, yeah.
You can't fucking beat up the grass, apparently.
Yeah.
Why can't I punch grass?
Champion.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Nice.
No.
It's dad's time.
It's always dad's time.
I should really get rid of Explosion.
I'm like now limited to moves.
It's like it's such a cool...
It's like...
It's just looking at me like that.
No.
My hot cheek is ruined.
All right.
Nice.
Oh, this guy wants to fight.
Oh, nice.
I knew it.
I knew there were things in there.
Fight me.
Heh.
It seems like a good target to nab some purple coins from.
Oh, yeah?
I got dad.
That's fucking right.
Holy shit.
I forgot about this guy.
That's right.
Get out of here.
What are you gonna do?
I have a king right here.
Okay.
See ya.
What's up, this?
Oh, fake out.
Is that gonna do nothing?
Jesus.
All of them have like critical hits.
No!
My item!
It's like he stole it or something.
It's like he's a thief.
Does it automatically go back in my pocket?
Oh my god.
It's like some sort of fucking thief.
No!
I'm not again.
Oh, he can't use that.
Oh, yeah.
I don't even remember what that item was.
I don't know what I gave him.
That was so long ago.
What kind of bandit would just steal from me?
No, we don't need to explode yet, guys.
We don't...
It's time to explode, Doki.
It's right there.
Oh, it was a sap bump.
Okay.
Okay, we can actually like give him a different item.
Ha!
Take that purple coin and get out of here!
Nice.
Okay.
Let's heal dad real quick.
No, randomly.
Will it heal dad ran...
Oh, it...
It was...
Who would have thought...
When he said heal randomly, it was actually heal randomly.
I don't know what I...
Well, I don't know what I was thinking, guys.
I...
For some reason, I thought something different will happen.
That gold finger...
We can't believe in our heals.
Alright, let's see.
Upon...
That restores HP upon striking the foe.
Oh, wait.
Is there a better one?
All Koopa Troopas...
It's so light...
It has...
It captures...
A plain mushroom that will sell...
Uh...
May latch onto foes.
Graduate stores HP...
Big nugget...
Red gem stored...
Raises the base...
Doubles money in battle if the holder takes...
Oh, wait!
I might as well do this.
No, he doesn't need it.
Money.
We like money.
Wait, we don't...
Wait, does it include purple coins?
Okay, we'll do shell belt.
Because we don't need money anymore.
We use...
We have 99...
Caps.
Hats.
Oh, I should give...
What was the evil like, dude?
I don't even remember.
Oh!
Nah, we don't care.
Oh, wait.
I bought this max nut.
I might as well use it.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
I might...
Take this max nut that...
That Ramli bought from a stranger.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
I bought that from a stranger, guys.
Okay.
Hey!
Do you know what star types Waluigi uses?
Yes, the stranger's max nut.
Oh!
Poison P. All right.
Use fire punch.
Punch him!
Punch that cactus!
All right.
It's okay.
Nice.
We heal a little bit.
My little 10 HP.
Keep punching him!
All right.
Oops.
Okay.
Maybe not now.
It's okay.
Now we keep punching him!
Nice.
Yay!
Slash?
Oh, air slash.
Wait.
That's a good move, right?
75.
Magnet bomb.
Rock throw.
Ooh.
Okay.
Let's get rid of headbutt.
We don't need a normal move.
We have Dragoon for that.
Get out of here.
What level does Dragoon evolve on?
Guys?
Do you guys remember?
Because I don't.
Oh!
Swoop!
That's cute.
50?
Oh my god.
We're not close.
Punch him!
Yeah!
Punch that bat!
All right.
No, you don't need to be fast.
Use Telf Puff?
Don't worry.
You can use any other Mario mod you want.
I know what I'm gonna do.
I just keep punching.
That's fucking right.
Just keep punching.
Yay!
That's right!
The poison!
Oh!
Waluigi uses poison!
Okay.
That's good to know.
It's not gonna do anything, though.
Okay, I should.
Yeah, fuck it.
That's fine.
I really need to heal Dad anyway.
I literally have, like, almost no more moves left.
Because he's purple!
He's herpa!
I'm not going.
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
Okay.
And then...
We go here.
Oh...
Here.
And then...
I chose the bottom.
So...
I...
I chose the same one again.
It happened so fast!
Okay.
And then I go the bottom.
Wait.
What?
Wait, what?
I paid for it!
There's a different path up?
Better is it?
Wait, what?
I have to pay for it again?
Oh, there's another switch to a five.
Do I have to pay?
Oh my
god.
I have to pay again?
She scanned me?
Wait, what?
I don't know.
What?
I don't wish you wouldn't do that.
Whoa!
Oh, it's this one!
Wait, how do I get to that one?
Wait, how do I get to there?
Okay.
No!
Why did Luigi wouldn't scare me?
Can't be a bad guy.
Here?
Oh, that just makes me go back.
I'm so lost.
Why do Luigi would never...
Okay, we go here.
Is it here?
Oh, it's here!
I did, I told you.
Waluigi would... I was just stupid, guys.
Waluigi would never scam me.
I was just being silly.
Okay.
Then it goes here.
Okay, so I don't go there.
Here, up.
Right, quick.
Where's the other monitor?
No!
Wait, what?
I pressed this monitor?
This monitor?
What changed?
Huh?
What?
What happened?
Oh, it...
No!
I have to read!
Get game bugged.
No!
My money!
Did it work?
Did it...
Gosh, it don't work.
It don't work!
Oh, it worked!
Yippee!
I knew it was me, guys.
It was my fault.
I knew Waluigi would never...
It's okay!
It was just me!
Maoshi would never do this to me!
Hey, so...
Why Mario?
You've arrived!
Tell me, Mario...
Are you...
A...
Gamer?
Wah!
I like to think my existence...
My purpose...
Is to become...
The ultimate gamer!
Golf!
Tennis!
Racing!
All are but a few examples...
About my gaming powers!
Wah!
Now...
A new game has been presented to me!
I must master it!
Mario!
You think you can defeat me?
The ultimate gamer?
Wah-ha-ha-ha-ha!
He-he-he-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Oh my god!
I'm fighting my Oshi!
The ultimate gamer!
You should give up now!
No use facing the ultimate gamer!
Oh my god!
He's so cool!
He's so fucking cool!
He doesn't need a proper gaming set!
That's how good he is!
What the fuck?
Who came in?
And what's that noise?
Oh my god!
Look!
Ah-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Ah-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
He's beautiful!
I need him!
I need him in my...
He's seen box.
He needs to be in.
Ah-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
He's beautiful...
Okay, obviously, I have to swap off.
So I'll swap the husky.
What is he gonna do?
Kill him?
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna whip you.
Oh, shit!
Oh!
Never mind.
Guess he's not getting whipped.
Wait.
Never mind.
I forgot.
Guys, it's a simple mistake.
I'll just headbutt.
Goodbye, husky.
Wait, wait, Hesley might be okay?
Alright, we'll try it.
No XP for you, husky.
Holy shit.
Okay, no XP for you too, I guess.
I... Jesus Christ!
Alright.
No XP for you as well.
Oh my god.
Guys, I think he actually is the ultimate gamer.
Guys, I think he might be... He might actually be the ultimate gamer.
You cheated!
I caught him baton pass!
Guys, I think he might be...
Oh, he wants to learn grudge.
Wait, what does grudge do?
Oh, no, we don't need that.
Yeah.
That's true... I don't know, but that can take him.
What the fuck is that?
He's gonna throw it.
I'm gonna cross chop.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, I keep forgetting that it's not very effective.
Whoops.
I... I don't know why.
I keep wanting to punch him.
I'm gonna burn it.
Wait, he can heal?
That's illegal!
Ultimate gamer should not be using items.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Explode, you know you want it.
Oh, no.
Dad, stop hurting yourself.
Dad, stop!
Stop hurting yourself!
I don't...
Oh, I don't have heal items.
Oh...
This is so bad.
Oh, I know if I kill him, I'm just gonna die by poison.
Um...
It's okay, Dragoon, this is it.
But I have... I have 99 hats, though.
I have 99 hats.
It's okay.
Just headbutt him.
Okay, nice.
Level 33.
Alright, I'm going to...
See if...
Oh, wait, I could...
No!
Okay, that's fine.
Headbutt.
How much damage do you do?
Okay, nothing.
Okay, it's fine.
We'll just keep headbutting.
Come on, Dragoon!
Just use your head!
Oh, shit.
Okay, that's bad.
Alright.
I have...
I have a plan.
I fall here.
Dad.
And then...
Dragoon may or may not...
Okay, he's not gonna die.
I could.
Okay.
And then...
I headbutt.
Oh my god.
Waluigi might have been the hardest one yet.
And then...
I headbutt.
No, Body Slam.
Goodbye, Dragoon.
Oh, shit!
I Body Slam.
Oh, goodbye Dragoon.
Never mind.
I forgot I'm slow.
Oh, shit.
Okay, this is it.
This is it.
Do we make... Oh, thank God.
We punch first.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, there's hope.
There's hope, guys.
Guys, I think, like, maybe putting it all in on...
I have an idea.
I... I have an idea.
Trust, guys.
It's time.
Let's see.
What?!
But you healed!
There's no way!
What?!
He said it healed!
I was scammed!
I was fucking scammed!
It was time to play dirty.
I can't believe it!
It's... I don't even remember what any of your moves are.
I don't even know.
What does anything do?
You have no attack?!
Attack!
Perish talk.
Okay.
We'll...
Oh my God.
Okay.
We'll use...
We'll use Perish talk.
We'll...
I don't...
I can't believe it.
We can do this.
Okay.
Alright.
And then I'll curse.
I can't...
That would've been so funny if it worked though.
That...
Guys.
It would've been so good if it didn't...
I'm so sad!
I'm so sad it didn't work!
It would've been so funny though!
It would've been so funny!
Oh fuck!
Oh shit!
Okay.
I said I'll...
This is very scary.
I...
I don't know if he'll live.
Oh fuck!
Okay.
Guys!
It might be over.
It might be over!
I don't have heals!
Guys!
I have zero heals!
Oh no....
Oh no!
Rest in peace!
He's- He was my first loss!
My actual...
First loss!
My actual first loss!
Oh my god!
Okay.
At least I'll whip my- NOOOOO!
NOOOOO!
He's- STOP!
Thank you for the super chat!
Yeah!
Waluigi is so strong!
You know I lost.
Dad heard me lose.
He's disappointed in me.
He's so... He's disappointed.
He's like, I can't believe you lost him!
We don't need heals.
We're so... We don't need it.
I've learned.
I've- No, I believe.
I... I learned!
It's okay.
I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
It's okay.
Why are you so mad?
It's not food time!
I don't know why he's mad.
Oh no, not baton pass.
No, not you!
No!
Not you!
How did I kill him?
I don't remember!
I forgot how I killed him.
Not food time!
No!
I'm not exploding!
Okay.
Head fight him.
You're right.
Wait.
Does Heftly survive this?
I don't remember.
Oh, I should curse him.
You're right.
I should.
Okay, but when... The moment I send Ryzen... She's gonna die.
Okay.
That's fine.
We'll headbutt him.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
We body... We'll headbutt.
Okay, I guess not.
I guess not.
I'm poisoned.
Nevermind.
Baby, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I guess not.
Oh my god.
You fucker.
That's it.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, sickbug.
You're taking this.
You're taking this for me.
Goodbye.
Oh, nice!
Alright.
Come and dance.
Dance for me.
Dance.
Oh, I ate his thing.
Okay.
We don't feel so good.
Go keep dancing!
Keep dancing!
Alright.
Nice.
Thanks for tanking it.
Alright.
Now that he's tanked it.
Now... Now, Dragoon, you can keep...
Keep headbutting him.
No, it's fine.
We don't need a heal.
Just keep headbutting.
He'll eventually kill him.
Okay.
You fucker.
Alright.
You know what?
I can tank it.
Yeah, I knew it.
I knew I could tank it.
Good.
Okay.
That's good.
He... I got... I got a little worried.
I... Dragoon, you will die for me.
You will have to die for it.
For the cause.
Yay!
No!
Dragoon, it's for the cause!
It's for the team!
No.
My life, fire.
My life, but don't keep... It was for the team, guys!
It was for... For the team!
It's for the greater good!
Remember us.
Witness.
I witnessed.
Okay?
Guys, I witnessed you.
No, it's fine.
It'll be okay.
I believe Dad will be fine.
You'll be fine, Dad.
Oh.
I don't know anymore.
It won't.
It'll be fine.
It'll be...
Okay, maybe he won't be fine.
Okay.
Alright, Rice.
I... What?
Okay.
Oh, guys.
No, I forgot to change!
Oh, fuck!
I pressed B!
He won't kill me, right?
He's not gonna kill me, right?
It'll be fine, right?
Oh, yeah.
I'll be fine.
Alright, punch.
Okay, nice.
That's critical.
That is good.
Alright, how many more?
Huff and Puff.
How do we kill Huff and Puff?
Oh.
I remember how we killed Huff and Puff.
That's like... How do... Oh, wait.
No, I remember.
I remember how we killed Huff and Puff.
I...
It's okay, we don't need to do that anymore.
We don't need- Guys, we don't need to do that anymore.
We- We sort of went kabloo-ee.
I know we didn't- I shouldn't use that, but I just couldn't be bothered.
Alright, now we use the other one.
Are you fucking kidding me?!
Okay, how much damage?
Okay, now...
What if I just- Now we do this.
No, no, no, it's fine.
I believe.
I believe in- AGAIN?!
You can't keep baton-passing each other!
You can't- You can't keep doing that!
Alright.
What's the point?
He spent time chaining.
That fucker!
Alright, Swoop.
Get out of here.
Punch!
Oh shit.
Oh fuck!
Oh, I forgot.
That was- It's time, Dad.
Oh, never mind.
You're strong.
Okay.
See, I told you.
I learned.
I figured- I just needed to sacrifice a couple of people.
For the cause.
What?
Waluigi disappeared?
And left behind the Casino Kingdom's power star?
First try.
Look at that.
What TM did I get?
Has the sound been okay throughout it?
I know I sound weird.
Waluigi's famous warp powder.
Shortcut to wherever your hearts desire.
Use the so-called- Yeah, sure.
Oh!
Oh, it took me back in the beginning.
Heh!
Think you can't get the power star without paying up?
The boss sends his regards.
Oh!
Oh, it was just 300.
From now on, you better be prepared to pay your interest on that loan you took from the boss.
And you don't have the purple coins?
Wait!
We'll start taking your actual coins, too.
Now then.
Scram!
Wait, what?
Wait, they...
They can take my...
Wait...
They can take my real coins?
Wait, so like...
But I have...
But I have 99 caps!
Wait...
Wait, what do I do?
What do I...
What?
Can I fight him?
Please, sir.
I didn't mean to.
Main Street is a dangerous...
Don't blame it on me.
Oh my god.
He...
What?
I...
What is the interest rate?
What?
Oh my god.
I gotta spend my money!
I gotta spend all my money!
If I spend all my money, they can't steal it from me.
Alright, I wanna see if I can...
Let me see if I can find a Shy Guy.
Okay, I'm gonna do five more encounters.
You're right, they can't steal any of I don't have money.
You're so right.
Alright, we're gonna see if we can find...
I'll do...
Two encounters.
Oh, I should save my game?
Yeah, I'll save it.
You're right.
Alright.
Bum bum.
Ba dum ba dum ba dum.
Alright, no Shy Guy.
God dammit.
I just wanna Shy Guy.
Guys, I have 99 hats.
I have 99 hats, guys.
So many hats.
Okay, let's go back to Toe Town.
Okay, we gotta spend our money.
We gotta spend our money before they take it off.
Let's see.
We need...
Okay, let's get healers.
Oh, what the TM is?
Okay, what is it?
Pocket.
Where are my TMs?
Key items...
Oh, there it is.
Fuse.
What did I get?
I don't remember what number it was.
Do you guys know?
Was it D...
Uh...
Was it Thief?
I have no idea.
Oh, 74?
Oh, it was Cross Poison.
Oh.
Okay, let's...
War Putt.
We gotta go to...
Diamond City.
So we can buy good items.
So he can't steal my items.
Can't steal my items if I'm fucking broke!
Let's go!
Is it here?
Buy.
Super Shroom.
Okay, we need that.
Buy three Super Shrooms.
Okay.
I already can't steal it.
What are you gonna do?
Break my...
Break my bones?
I like to see them try.
Can't break my bones if I break them first!
I don't remember what each floor has.
Oh, it's for this.
To know my kneecaps.
Can't steal my organs if I sell my organs first!
Think about that.
Okay, we'll buy...
Actually...
Yeah, we'll buy Antidote too.
Just buy more healers.
There we go.
True.
If I lick all of my coins, they won't steal it as well.
Oh my god.
Good plan.
Good plan, guys.
Good plan!
Oh wait, not here.
Alright, Dragoon!
Lick them!
Dragoon!
Lick it!
I licked my coins!
Is this world...
World 5?
We're in the tall grass area.
Uh-huh!
Club Cros is thinking of the Super- Oh!
It's a Wiggler!
Okay!
You know what that means.
Go.
Oh my god.
Okay, I realized that we are... Wait.
We got to die instantly.
Wait a minute.
Okay, I realized the wiggler is, like, pretty strong.
Oh, wait.
I want to see how angry it looks.
How angry will you be?
Oh my god, he angry.
Oh my god, why did you guys tell me to make him...
Okay, I can use an ice storm throw then.
Now, congrats, now he's at six... Wait.
You can't jump if I throw a ball at you.
That's right.
Oh, never mind, you can't.
Never mind.
Alright.
I'm sorry, stick bug.
I'm sorry.
Goodbye.
Someone has to die.
Get stick bug.
I'm eating chips right now.
Yay!
Who wants to be wiggler?
Okay.
It's the...
Um...
The honey Dijon one.
You know the...
The kettle chips?
I love those.
A caterpillar, the worst temper in the world.
If you ever see one moving...
Alon, choose your actions carefully.
It's trampling powers.
It's incomparable.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, do you hear me?
My crunches?
I've seen a lot of angry...
But this one might be the angriest red.
What?
Not so joker.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
I mute.
Ha ha ha!
It's Mehdi's fault.
Alright.
Who wants to be wiggler again?
I don't remember.
I was eating my chips.
Just remember whose fault it is.
Ha ha ha!
Me!
Alright, Sai.
I'll give it to you.
Sai Goon.
Goon.
Alright.
Zanir!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, I'm a pretty angry dude.
If you're still taking super names...
Oh, don't worry.
You can beat this guy.
Ha ha ha!
The opposite of the...
The wiggler.
Ha ha ha!
Zanir Man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm gonna be this guy.
This fucking garlic looking thing.
Oh my god.
I'm asleep.
I'm just gonna throw the ball.
Just for the sake of it.
Wait.
I almost had it.
I'm gonna just throw another one.
Yeah!
A flower that yearns for flight.
When it blooms, it'll spin around and creates platforms for others to jump and launch.
Spreading its pollen.
All right.
Zander Goon.
How many mons is there in this game, anyway?
Oh, just enough.
I feel like we've encountered so many already.
Wonder 51.
Oh, it's just like the original.
Just like the original.
Oh my god.
I have to...
Let me just heal him.
Fuck it.
I'm just gonna use it now.
I can't be bothered.
I heard there's...
Yeah, there's like one legendary or something, right?
All right.
Let's get out of here.
Anything else?
Oh!
It's Dino Rino!
Oh, it's this guy.
I remember this guy.
I remember from what game, but I remember...
No, it's from...
Ah, blah, blah, blah.
What?
My favorite Mario game.
I know this.
This is from my favorite Mario game.
Oh, I forgot the name of it.
I love this game.
Yeah, from Mario World.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
From Mario World.
Super Mario World.
It's my favorite one.
Oh, I keep... whoops.
I used the move twice because I was like, I'm gonna... I don't know why it didn't work.
I didn't read it, so I'll use it again.
I was like, why didn't it work?
Well, whatever.
Let me use it again.
Alright, time to catch him.
Yay!
Donorano!
It wants to be Donorano.
A hulking herby-vorous dinosaur.
When it reaches maturity, it learns to give up its fire, but...
This is seen as a rite of passage.
Thank you for the super chat, Carl.
Thank you, thank you.
Can I be Donorano?
Yeah, you can!
Alright, Carl.
Hehehe.
My Donorano.
Carl.
Hehehe.
Carl!
Why, Carl?
Why?
Alright, Carl-goon.
Alright.
I wonder if I can use a Yoshi...
Oh, I can't.
The tall grass won't let me use a Yoshi-wissa.
Okay, I don't know if there's any more...
...blood encounter.
So I'm gonna...
I'm just gonna head down.
Who's that?
Bowser?
Again?
Tell me I gotta be Frank.
Of course, my Frank.
No, I mean...
How'd you do that?
Do what?
You...
Do not...
My...
My name is not Frank.
Oh, thank you, sire.
But what I was gonna say...
The harsh reality is that we're not getting those Power Stars before Mario will.
We just can't keep up.
But, sire.
Then we just keep trying.
Oh, oh, oh.
You didn't let me finish.
We may not keep up.
But someone else can.
Luigi, you fuck.
I knew it.
Wow.
The jungle kingdom is looking extra green today, bro.
I wonder where I'll get my fifth Power Star.
Better get a move on.
Kamek, my dearest ally.
I had to say it.
But I'm not having much fun anymore.
Your Highness.
I am flabbergasted.
Surely running around these different wonderfully colorful worlds have enticed you to keep playing along.
Has it not?
Yes, it's true.
Even after I mercilessly defeated Mario every single encounter we have.
I'm just not having a good time.
Then, maybe it's best we go home.
Pousey.
You're not having fun with your captures?
Mamma mia.
Luigi.
Sorry, I didn't see you there.
We were just about to leave.
You're quitting the challenge, bro.
Okay, this has gone long enough.
Luigi.
Come with us.
We're getting power stars.
Okay, then.
Oh my god, Luigi.
You're beta.
He's just like, okay.
Luigi.
You just let him pick you up like that.
This is why we don't have Year of Luigi anymore.
We don't have Year of Luigi because of you.
Okay, I'm gonna do two more encounters and see if I can get anything else.
Cause I know you guys said there's two more that I'm missing.
I'll do two more.
Oh, what the fuck is that?
It's a bird!
I'm gonna punch this bird.
My target was too heavy.
No, don't say that to Dad!
Yes, it's not his fault.
He's peeing out his protein.
It's not his fault.
Wow.
He's a big boy!
He's a growing boy!
I can't believe it.
He fat shamed my dog.
Alright, who wants to be Klepto?
The fat shamer.
That's just big bones!
Lord of Croesus.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If you encounter a Rex or a T-Rex, can I be renamed from Goomba to that?
Lord of Croesus.
The Mon chose you.
You can't just...
You can't just revoke the Mon.
He picked you.
Annoying avian, an atrocious adversary, has a keen sense of valuable possession, will do anything to take it, because it has no value in itself!
Oh shit!
So, he has no self-esteem, or like, any confidence, whatsoever.
Who would like to be him?
He's just like me, for real, for real.
Wait, Thunder...
Let's not have one yet, right?
Alright.
That's...
Me.
Alright.
Wait, I was joking.
Okay, alright.
You were...
Okay, I'll give it to Mel, then.
That's me!
Mel, alright.
Does Mel have...
I've named so many.
I'm, you know...
Does Mel have...
Uh...
Have a goon yet, or no?
I've named so many, I've already lost track of who I've named.
I...
No, alright.
Low se...
Mel is now...
Low self-esteem bird.
No...
But you choose to name me as the...
The goon chose you, Lord Korosis!
It picked you!
Now there's two more left?
Okay.
Oh, I can't escape.
Abso, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He's just like me for real, for real.
Okay, I'll do...
I'll go...
I'll do like two more encounters again.
Cause I...
Oh!
It's the monkey!
It's the boss monkey!
I'm punching it.
Oh my god.
I'm confused.
Okay, I hope I don't kill the monkey.
Guys, I accidentally killed the monkey.
I...
Guys, I accidentally...
Whoop!
Um...
Guys, is the monkey a rare encounter?
Guys, is the monkey...
Guys, is the monkey the rare encounter?
Because...
Oh...
Oh no!
No!
We got another monkey!
Alright, I'm punching it again.
I'm...
I'm punching...
Okay, fine!
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
This will...
It'll work this time.
Okay, there.
See?
I told you.
It worked, guys.
Don't punch the monkey.
I'll punch it again.
Alright.
The next time you have a gaming membership, I want you to remember this.
Thank you for the super chat.
Gross.
Thank you, thank you.
A cute monkey that loves to play games.
It will often stay in trees and look for things to steal from people.
But with enough persistence, they'll give it back.
Alright.
Who wants to be the monkey?
I wish for monkey.
Alright, heathen.
You are the monkey.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I like...
The petition to be punched.
To be the punched monkey.
Well, he's...
Which...
The one that died?
You mean...
The one that killed?
Well, we can't get him back.
So...
Heathen.
Moon.
Alright.
There's one more, right?
There's one more encounter.
Left.
It's not his feeding time.
He wants to eat early because he tricked me into feeding him early this morning.
He like...
I love this one!
I'm still punching it.
Oh my god!
It's Rex!
Rex!
I'm still punching it.
Please, please, please live.
Oh, thank god.
He lived.
Thank god.
Yes!
The Super Mario World!
What if there's already a goon with the same on?
Could they...
No.
Papa.
You were...
The goon chose you.
Oh my god!
That was so scary!
Okay, so...
So, basically, dad tricked me into...
What the fuck?
He squashed!
He tricked me into feeding him early.
Because he woke me up at 6.30.
And then I thought it was 8.
I didn't realize it was, like, super early.
So then, like...
Um...
So then I fed him.
And then I looked at the time.
It was 6.30 in the morning.
And I was like, you fucker.
You...
So, like...
Technically, it is his squish time.
Not squish...
It is his feet.
Sorry.
Not squish...
I'm not squishing my dog.
Technically...
Oh, he's egg.
Okay, I'm gonna give him a little snack.
I'm giving him a little snack, though.
I'll be right back.
I gave him...
I gave him a little snack.
To tide the hunger.
Because I don't want him to, like, fuck me up tomorrow.
I...
A flightless dragon, in light of its useless wings, adopts a charging attack.
When provoked, it compresses his body as a defense mechanism.
Um...
Alright.
Who...
Okay.
Ancestor Goon.
Goon Alpha.
Lollipop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Can I beat this?
Oh my god.
There's so many.
Alright, guys.
It's time to vote.
Has to be named after Rex.
Told no.
She immediately runs into...
Alright, guys.
Vote for the one you want to be named Rex.
He's a hot commodity.
Right now.
It's time to vote.
The super chat.
Vote for the super chat that you want to be named.
He's a hot commodity right now.
It's time to vote.
We will settle this with democracy.
The super chat still exists.
We shall settle this with pure democracy.
Except for Kurosis.
No, he gets to...
No, Kuro...
We are not giving Kurosis.
The goon picked him.
Everything but...
Everyone but Kurosis.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh wait.
I have to res...
Oh my god.
Wait.
My super chat bugged out.
Guys, I refreshed my thing and I lost some super chats.
Let's give me a sec.
Oh no.
Guys.
My super chat's bugged out.
Who won?
Thomas.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I want...
I wish...
But no lying.
Okay.
I'm gonna do like a countdown though.
Five.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Okay.
Let's see.
29 for Oni.
Alright.
29 is the number to beat.
Okay.
Oni got it.
I think.
Alright.
Congratulations, Oni.
No, Kurosis already got like fucking yeeted out of the polls.
Oni a goon.
Oh, thank you so much for the raid.
Thank you.
Alright.
Now I can leave.
Oh, I should fix the goon cave.
Cause now it's like the non-goon cave.
Cause now it's like the non-gooners are in the goon cave and I don't like that.
Alright.
So...
We'll put you guys right...
We'll put you here.
Okay.
Alright.
I see a pink shirt.
Oh, okay.
Put you guys here.
Alright.
What would box three be?
Box three will be...
Uh...
Box three...
What would box three be?
What's crag?
Where the fuck is crag?
Crag?
The fuck does crag mean?
Alright.
I don't know.
I don't know what to name box three.
Box three.
Oh, it's...
Oh, there's...
It's rocks?
Oh, that's what it means?
Oh!
Alright.
Name it...
Shame?
You...
I know what to name it.
Right in the space?
Private...
Room.
I don't...
Wait, actually...
Private...
VIP room.
This is a VIP room.
Exclusive.
So then, if it's the private room...
Should be...
Oh, it should be on the beach.
Ooh.
Wait, no, but it's a room.
This should be in the city.
Ooh.
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
What goes on in there?
Nothing.
You gotta sign an NDA.
You always have to sign an NDA.
Let's go to the PC first.
just...
So we can heal everybody.
Alright.
Bum, bum, ba-da-da-da-dom.
Bum, bum, bum, ba-da-domp.
Alright, down I go.
Kay, already encountered all the mons so I don't have to worry anymore...
Oh, wait, is this Donkey Kong one?
Oh!
Which version?
The Seth Rogen one or...
Which version of Donkey Kong is that?
Oh my god, I'm in Donkey Kong!
Ooh, ah, ee.
Mario!
Oh.
Money!
Money running into you here!
It's me!
Captain Toad from Cloud Cap!
You seem stuck!
Is something wrong?
You can't understand the Kong Guard and they won't let you pass?
Maybe I can help with that.
I've been brushing up on my monkeys!
Ooh, ah, ee, ee.
Ee, ee!
He says you need to defeat them in a wild battle!
To get an entry in the kingdom!
But don't you wait!
Me
and battle together!
Man!
This monkey is a strong!
You have one bond, Captain Toad?
It's okay.
I know what to do.
What?
Uh...
You know...
You know what to do!
Okay, maybe we shouldn't.
Maybe...
Maybe we shouldn't fucking...
Explode!
Nice!
Goodbye, monkey!
Don't be rash there!
Well, calm down, Toadki!
Calm down!
You know what the heart wants!
I'll just chop him!
Chop the dino!
Make them extinct another time!
Oh, wait!
You can transform?
Why did you transform into fire?!
Oh, cause it's sunny!
Nevermind!
It's like a cascoon!
Absol!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Memories of me knocking out my rival's Pokemon because I wanted all the glory in the double battles!
Yeah, it's a cast form!
Yeah, I was gonna be like, Are you stupid?!
Why did you change the fire?!
And I realized you...
It wasn't a choice!
Oh, wait!
Dad has always been...
Does more damage if the user outweighs the foe!
Um...
Sorry, Dad!
You're a pretty head!
Better than...
Okay!
I would say it's better than fire punch!
We might need it!
We...
Okay!
Alright!
Do we get rid of...
Fire punch or explosion?
I'm not calling!
I'm just calling him that he's heavier than the other...
Other...
Other dogs that get me!
Explosions!
Stays!
Okay!
You're right!
We get rid of fire punch!
You're so right, guys!
What if I need explosion?
You don't understand!
It'll come in handy!
Ah!
Ooh!
E!
Ah!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Hi, Toki!
First time donate!
Hey!
Thank you so much for the super chat!
We've been enjoying your time here!
Ooh!
Way to go!
The path is now open!
See!
It seems like you'll need a translator to keep going!
And potentially a battle partner!
I'll tag along!
I thought they could talk...
What do I...
Italian?
Woohoo!
Maya and Captain O take on the jungle kingdom!
Do they not speak Italian?
You...
Ah!
Jump panel!
You may already know this!
But I can't jump!
Why are you following me?
I don't need a translator!
I'll beat them all up!
How about we split up?
I think we'll need to show off our individual skills to get through the jungle kingdom!
Alright!
Talk to me!
And ask me to go solo!
Hey!
Okay.
Go solo.
You didn't press RF focus to camera me and move me around!
Try it out!
Hey!
What if I don't wanna press the RF button?
Woohoo!
I think we're ready!
Alright.
Let me talk to you.
I wanna steal your...
What do you have?
Oh!
I can't just steal it.
I was gonna be like, show me your bag!
I may or may not have wanted to steal his stuff.
Okay.
Oh wait, I should save.
Wait, Toad?
Oh, that's me!
I'm Toad!
I was like, wait a minute.
I'll save real fast.
I showed you my bag.
Please respond.
I wanted to steal his stuff.
Oh, I have the power glove.
Oh!
We make a great team!
Let's press on!
Eh?
What do I do here?
Oh!
You want to move from here?
No way!
You don't even have an apartment to force me in a wild battle!
Okay, so...
I have to go here.
EEEE!
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, I went Toad.
E.
Ah.
Oh.
E-I-E-I-O.
By the way, any caps you catch with...
Are you fucking kidding me?
What?
That fucker...
Alright, it's time.
He crashed!
It's time!
That's right.
Crush that monkey!
Yes!
Crush the monkey!
That was strength zap.
Zaps the foes attack to heal them drops attack?
The fuck?
Eh, fuck it.
I don't think we need Tail Whip.
That monkey is dead!
Squish him!
You know like that crushed image where like...
It's like a butt imprint?
Flam butt imprint?
Okay, am I...
Is he heavier?
But we'll find out.
Alright, nice.
Oh shit!
It's pretty strong!
Wait, you fell down?!
Oh my god, get out of here.
Fly!
Crush him!
Yay!
Oh nice, sick bug leveled up.
Ooh.
Okay.
No, there's no boulders here.
Wait, where else can he go?
I can't go anywhere!
I have to wait here!
Okay, wait, let me move my...
Uh...
Actually, no.
We might have to keep him here.
Is there any new encounters in the tall grass?
Or...
Let's see.
I wanna see if there's new encounters.
Guys, you know there's new encounters?
Or no?
No, I'm not catching any of his toad.
He'll just have one.
Because apparently, he doesn't, like, go back...
Like, I don't get to keep the mods he captures, right?
Oh my god!
It's the little guy with the blanket!
Oh, I have to catch another to progress!
That's what he means!
Oh!
I'm gonna crush a bird!
That makes sense.
I was so confused.
I'm squishing...
Oh my god!
And he puts the sun out for me?!
Nice.
Bird pancake time.
Oh, return?
No, you're not learning that.
Bulk up.
What is that?
Is that...
Brown...
Brass?
Can't tell.
I'm gonna fucking crush it.
I'll just air slash it.
Oh, it's grass fighting?
Oh, wait, that's good!
Yay!
Momento.
No.
Get out of here!
Oh, wait, you're right!
You are named after professors.
I just noticed that.
His name is Juniper.
That's clever!
Is there anything here?
No, there isn't.
Alright.
I have to catch a Mon for Toad.
Alright, Toad.
Catch something.
We need one more.
Alright.
Good enough.
What the fuck?
What's Snowscape?
I should have read.
I should have read his moves.
Alright, throw the hammer at this bird!
Oh my god.
He's so weak.
So...
Alright, I assume that like...
I get like...
I assume I get like other stuff, right?
Like when I use the...
Yeah, if I use like the weather moves, I assume like when I change, it gets stronger in weather.
Alright, one of you guys can rename yourself.
One of you guys can rename yourself the Fitback Goon.
And...
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna win this one.
I...
Okay, we'll use Rain Dance.
Wait.
I might be able to pick him up.
Can't be that heavy.
No, I can't use fire because the Dino will just like absorb it.
No!
Oh wait, I did it!
I took you up in the air!
I knew you weren't that heavy.
Okay, so now I have a Boomerang.
Wait, why is my Boomerang flying?
Oh, nice!
Oh, it's so strong!
Okay, good.
Okay, I...
I'm gonna...
That's actually really good.
I kidnapped you.
Nice, I crit it.
Okay, Boomerang.
Sky drop.
I'll take you up in the air.
It's alright.
Yeah, that was crazy.
Okay, that should kill him.
Right?
Yeah, it should.
He's literally like falling from the fucking sky.
It should kill him from impact alone.
On Wild Battles, bud.
Here, have these!
Oh, nice!
Just doing it for the sake of it.
Okay.
And then...
There you go.
So that should open...
Yeah, that should open the gates then.
Yay!
So what's this?
Oh, I can go down the waterfall?
Oh my god, not the stupid stick bug.
Stupid fucking stick bug.
Okay, I wanna grab that item before I go down the waterfall.
Okay, thank god I looked.
Con... Covert cloak.
Alright, down I go.
Yay!
Oh, there he is!
Yes!
Okay.
We're catching.
Oh my god.
There it is.
There he is.
He has returned.
I'm too...
Perfect for the goon.
That yes came from the heart.
No!
Yes, I'm too lazy to evolve cheap right now.
Okay, we'll put Husky...
Goon in here.
So he can stun him.
If he lives.
He lives.
Okay.
And then we'll stun Spore.
Alright.
And then...
Whip him!
Yes!
I'll just...
Use stun Spore to like...
As a throwaway move.
Alright.
Baseball cat.
Yay!
Cheap chomp was caught!
Alright.
Who wants to be him?
You know where what...
You know what box you're going into though.
Just...
A bigger-lipped fish.
It's appetite is unmatched.
It prowls shallow waters and swallows its prey whole.
Whoa!
It is the subject of rumors and ghost stories.
Oh, apparition?
Wait.
Ipu.
Has Ipu been named yet or no?
Wait.
Didn't Delta want it to be named?
Actually.
I heard that Del Delta has been like...
Asking to be named for a long time.
Del...
Here you go.
You asked...
And you received it.
Put me in that box.
Thank you for the secret chat.
Thank you.
I got bamboozled.
Don't worry.
I'll find another one.
Oh.
Is that what you really wanted?
Is...
I can find another one for you, Ipu.
The monkey paw girl.
Don't worry.
I got you, bro.
Is that...
I...
I did not realize you were so passionate about...
Don't worry.
We needed more of these guys anyway.
Put them together alone in a box.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
It's all the fucking stupid stick bugs.
All right.
Let's see.
I'll do two more encounters.
If we don't get him...
We'll find another...
We'll find him again in another day.
Oh.
No worries.
Don't worry.
The game was like...
No.
We really...
Wait.
I got this.
Don't leave.
All right.
Nice.
You thought I'd kill that.
You were hoping he died.
You were...
All right.
Stun spore.
Don't worry.
I got you, Ippu.
That's what you wanted, right?
I got you.
See?
I didn't bamboozle you.
You asked and you received.
Ha ha ha ha,ha ha ha ha!
Yeahh,
thank you.
Good.
No.
Bloody crisis.
Thank you in the super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh you're not going to the exile box.
I'm not letting you off that easy.
All right.
Actually...
That's where Dell would go.
Oh, and then... Where's... Where's Kuro... Okay.
There we go.
Have fun.
Perfect.
Alright.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
He kicked me out.
Alright.
I have to, like, physically move Toad over?
That's so dumb.
Like, he's right there!
Can't let you in town unless you defeat us in a 2v2.
I'm trying!
What?
Oh, with Mario.
Okay.
What?
Oh, I have to talk to Toad.
Okay.
Stupid.
That should be super!
There shouldn't be anything left in our way to a jungle village!
Okay, go together.
Alright.
Come over here.
He says he won't let you in town unless we defeat him in a wild battle!
Yeah, we're ready.
Okay.
I was like, he's- You're right here!
I don't have- I shouldn't be forced to, like, fucking- Talk to Toad to activate this.
Alright.
I must be- Dad must be heavier.
Must be heavier.
What if I just squish him?
I- I just go and squish my own teammate.
Zero!
Chris, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you- Thank you!
There we go.
I knew it.
Yeah, I'm not gonna crit him.
I was like, he better- He's like the fucking king of the bombs!
The sunlight is so strong!
Oh, wait, they have two?
Wait, that's cheating!
Oh, it's the fish bone.
I don't think I can crush him, so I'll just throw him.
What the fuck?
What'd he do?
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah, cause he's- Why- Why did you use fire on him?!
Oh, wait, it's- No, he just has several moves.
Jesus Christ!
Oh!
Fuck, I forgot he's a ghost.
I forgot.
Oh, that's awkward.
Alright, snow time.
Oh, now he's an ice bro!
Oh, Jesus.
That's so strong.
Wait, is this the hill?
No, it doesn't do hill damage.
Okay, I literally just need to hit one of them.
Alright, that's fine.
That barely does any- Okay, that does a lot.
Never mind.
Why did you change your moveset?!
Toad, please!
Please!
Toad!
Oh my god.
Please, Toad!
Jesus Christ, Toad.
You fucker.
I literally just needed you- I literally just needed you- Oh, what if- Am I- Am I like- Stronger?
Am I heavier than- Than chain chomp?
Let's find out.
Toad.
I swear to god.
Please.
Toad.
I- I swear to god.
Toad!
I expected you to- Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
I'm mad too!
Toad!
Wait thirty more minutes!
I'm also mad!
Toad, why?!
Oh my god.
Toad has like fuck- Toad!
Please!
I need to hit one person!
What?
Why?
No.
Okay, do we feed him early?
Do I give in, guys?
Do we give in?
He's not asking.
Why?
It's because he... It's because he tricked me and made... He tricked me into feeding him early.
And now he is mad.
And now... No.
Don't give in.
Okay, we wait.
We just need to wait.
We literally need to wait 30 more minutes.
Oh my god.
We need to wait 30 more minutes.
Yeah, I'm closing the door.
I'm confused.
He was like, you closed the door?
He said he didn't think he was a super chap that he made.
Alright.
Nice.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, and Takti does more of him.
Yeah, nobody's gonna be fainting.
We did it, Mario!
We said we'd go in!
Nice.
What's going on?
Bowser, bro.
I'm shocked you've gotten four power stars without knowing how to properly utilize items.
Wait, that's me!
Yeah, yeah.
Hey, Luigi.
Can you please explain in excruciating detail what every item does?
Certainly, bro!
Mushrooms are healing items that you can use in the middle of battle.
There are different varieties that restore different amounts of health.
Have you located the golden banana?
Yes, my sneeziness.
They're as deep in the safari zone.
He is a min-maxer.
He is.
I bet he IV trains, too.
Perfect.
Start mobilizing our troops with haste.
Ah.
Mario, great to see you again.
You've met Luigi, right?
Hey, bro!
I'm gonna be with Bowser for a bit.
I'm teaching how fun this game is!
That's right.
Luigi's gonna be helping out from now on.
So you better watch your back because our next fight will be a total and utter victory.
Minions!
We're getting the golden...
I mean, the next power star!
It was the golden banana.
Bro!
Isn't this great?
Luigi!
Are you sure this is a good decision?
Of course, bro!
Everyone deserves to have a fun.
It's a game, of course.
Anyway, I'm going with Bowser to Khan Capital.
I hope to meet you, too.
There.
I have a bad feeling about all this.
But, there's nothing else we can do but play along.
Let's head to World 5, too, whenever we're ready!
Wait for me!
Ooh, I bet that Cooper joke is up to no good.
What's this?
Oh!
Oh, is this, like, the Pokemon Center?
Yeah!
Oh, I don't want that.
I'm so worried that...
No.
I'm so worried I accidentally pressed yes.
Thank goodness someone here speak something out here than monkeys!
I feel like we're going insane trying to understand the cons and they're wild and battles!
It's literally double battle.
How does he not understand that?
Okay.
Oh, there's a Yoshi!
Noshin!
Hmm.
I don't really trust those Koopas that were here earlier.
Oh, is this a Mario?
Want to buy some tasty goodies?
Where are they?
Oh, Yoshi cookies!
All saddest problems.
Oh, that's so cute!
Oh my god, they're little monkeys!
Mushroom, super shroom, ultra shroom.
Okay, we need this.
Okay, we'll buy two of these.
We have to buy them or else or else he's gonna or else they're gonna come and get me, guys.
I...
Guys, I have to spend all my money, guys.
Or they're gonna get me.
They're gonna...
Okay, there we go.
That's a cat.
Talk to that guy on the right counter and he'll help fill that thing up.
I'm too scared.
Cookies are the best things to eat, but Yoshi cookies provides all the essential nutrients for a goring body, but only for Yoshis.
He can still eat them to heal status almonds.
Ooh, banana.
Oh, outsiders?
You simply have to stay and learn the special move I recently learned.
Wonderful!
It's called grassy glide.
Okay, we're not learning that.
I know, but like, I'm scared.
I'm not...
I'm not risking it.
Lord, Bowser knew you'd be following us, so he told us to stay put.
Come on, Mario.
We can beat them in a battle.
Yeah, and...
Oh my god!
Oh my god, they threw him away!
What are you doing?
We supposed to accept the challenge!
That's part of the rules!
Who told you that we follow the rules?
Mario!
Wait, that's illegal!
Now then, how about we fight fairly?
Wait, they just...
Wait, is he...
How will he survive that?
They just needed him!
Okay, to be fair, him...
them...
throwing away toad actually helps us.
Like...
Because we can actually...
We can actually progress the game now.
Like...
That's good, we needed him out.
Oh my...
Oh wait, that doesn't do anything.
That should work, right?
Nice.
Okay.
Toad was 100%.
If you don't lie and say he wasn't, we all know he was 100% dead weight.
All right.
Slash him!
Okay, that should kill him, I was gonna say.
Yay!
U-turn?
What is U-turn?
Then switch is...
No, you don't do that.
You stay and fight till you die.
Okay, sucker punch.
Okay, what does sucker punch do?
Fight strikes first if the foe is preparing an attack.
Oh, we don't need struggle bug.
All right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I love how the minions battle theme is Bowser's battle theme to Mario and Luigi's Bowser's inside story.
Showtime!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I love like...
Oh wait, we can burn him.
I love the music in this one, especially when you're doing like...
Oh fuck, okay, never mind.
No!
It protected himself!
No, okay, whoops.
Yeah, the music is so good, especially when they made it like...
What's the version called?
Is it like...
8-bit songs?
Is that what it's called?
How do I keep lynching?
Not 8-bit?
What is it called?
Like, those types of tracks?
Chip tunes?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is it chip tunes?
Like, they make it like that type, especially songs that didn't have a chip tune before.
How do I keep lynching?
Punch the bullet!
Yes!
All right, there's one more.
Hold up, trooper.
All right, we're squishing him.
Okay, we're squishing him next move.
Okay.
Now...
Now we're squishing him.
Boom.
Leave that imprint.
I throw a rock and I squish.
Yay!
We did it!
Our master plan!
Ruin!
Okay, your plan was literally the Chuck Toad.
Oh!
Looks like I've been separated from Mario!
I better make it back to him as soon as possible!
All right, we leave now.
We'll let future Jokey worry about that.
I think it's a good stopping point.
We played...
We played a lot of progress today.
We finished the world.
I think it's a good stopping point.
Oh!
That was fun!
Yeah, we've been playing for four hours.
Ah!
I had a great time!
This game is really fun.
I like the...
I don't know.
I just really enjoyed the...
I really enjoyed the story so far and just like messing around by capturing drag wounds.
Oh, you guys have been enjoying this playthrough!
I don't even know how much we have left.
I think we have like four more worlds, right?
So like...
We could...
I think...
Okay, to be fair, we got very distracted in the Waluigi world.
But I had a lot of fun so far.
I hope you guys have been having fun watching.
Um...
I have to feed dad soon.
But...
Sageon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks, Stokey.
Thank you, guys.
I'm glad you guys have been enjoying it.
I'm happy to be streaming again.
Um...
I always forget, like...
No, not forget.
I always, like, get scared and be like, oh my god.
What if, like, I just forget how to stream whenever I take these, like, breaks and stuff?
And then we can fix our microphone and, like, adjust the sound setting so I sound less weird.
Um...
But yes, thank you, everybody.
Thank you, everybody, for watching.
Um...
I wanna say, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and run around to get that blood flowing.
And if you say it for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.